okay so
oh i didn't realize that you can't play
a8 x rook d2 or rook b2 and then you
just take the pawn on b4 oh king of six
rook before bishop v7 only chance if you
go first things before bishop e7 but
then rook b8 and then black gives up an
exchange and he's got chances why
doesn't four seconds how does he oh my
god he doesn't know bishop seven they're
chances take his seven
one play for b1 if you leave repeat one
oh
my gosh
oh my gosh that didn't just happen
oh
oh my god i've never seen anything like
this in my life
oh and he's he is just destroyed
emotionally right now oh my god
how
what in the world i didn't even see the
mate
me neither rook f2 rook after bishop
coming to d3 fabby with 15 seconds what
he does with you on bending the queen
queen three pinning the bishop wait wait
gigi oh my goodness a queen h3 oh my
goodness he's queen
it's not all over his queen's coming
either to e6 or to h6 how is he doing
this 15 seconds this is anybody seven
it's the time scramble
take it take the girl you can take the
rope oh my goodness
bishop before that immediately after he
played it what's going on eight seconds
seven seconds who's gonna win this g4
betting the queen bishop
good the c6 push it oh my gosh oh my
goodness
he promotes he promoted but he's going
for three seconds he's got the three
seconds take the call in the pawn he
just pawn take it take the pun
oh my goodness and it's going to be a
draw oh my god
but still how did he say that in fact
he's going to be annoyed with himself
that he didn't win that let me tell you
oh bishop d5 23 is hanging so yeah
really dangerous
a4 now he wants abby to take so he can
put a rook on d2 yes and that's not good
he's going to move he's going to lose
oh my god the position where fabby
resigns after bishop d5 are you kidding
me
his feet were stuck in cement and he
couldn't budge and he doesn't get a move
off and fabiano carwana in a lost
position he couldn't get out of the
quicksand
six seconds for david black's gotta make
moves faster rook h2ok2 come on
black is really slow so is david
oh
i think david's gonna flag him he's
giving the right checks
he missed it take the quiz
oh my
goodness night back to f1 amazing oh my
god you have to oh you steal me you
should have made a bishop you could have
flagged him with a bishop oh my gosh
does
slightly worse cyborgs fetish sam still
qualified wait no
no we didn't and jeffy
qualifies
the stalemate gets him through
this is unreal
oh my gosh
he surpasses fetishes of poor vladimir
by less than one tiebreak point
he carries the white house
yeah he knows his biggest advantage is
in time scrambles does he make a berlin
draw very quickly to get to the three
plus two hello
[Music]
robert
i'm just throwing it out there i'm just
throwing it out there robert
yes anna
you called it
[Laughter]
oh boy oh boy and we have a very quick
draw because what hikaru is saying
is you can have the white pieces fabiano
but in three minute plus two second
increment i am king if dc3 there might
even be rook takes 66
[Music]
he knows it's there he knows it's there
and he finds it and he plays it
wow you could play rook d1 you could
think about queen takes beat just takes
on b7 because the rook more precise
oh my gosh checkmate afterwards it's
over what a game it takes on b7 first to
cut the king the black king has nowhere
to go rook t1 is the winning threat as
well as the hanging group plus queen c7
there's just way too much going on i
didn't even think about queen so
christian's mate is made in one
oh my gosh he has to see maiden one
right
that's game game over
oh my gosh that is checkmate that is
fabiano caruana saying you sure you want
to play me in blitz i can handle myself
right
but it was oh my god the bell slipped
oh my slip i think he was trying to play
h3
he was trying to play h3 and somehow the
rook got to h3 and not the pawn
that
has happened to me so many times you
click the square and then you click the
piece by accident
and it moves to the square oh my lance
could have had three results in this
game
we definitely could have
pre-moved bishop g he primo bishop h5
just what i was gonna say it's gonna be
in a draw and then we're gonna have a
tie breaker but no david ferrari tricks
in the parliament oh my fabiano has
missed this when he moved bishop to d1
and now he is
desperately trying to find the defense
but there is none
no defense king comes well c2 and there
it is we have a champion wow
wow lavon his first time in the finals
and he makes it count seventy five
hundred dollars richer
the levon is a beautiful person to begin
with but i think what his sentiments and
what he said was really inspiring
indeed and i don't think level wants to
leave us so we can still talk about the
carpet too because
i i actually i totally and
wholeheartedly agree with you yesterday
you have never said anything nice about
that
exactly
he dropped a rook
oh
he made a pre-move he made him remove
kj3
this is such a weird position
he's like defending the
you know checkmate on f7 with his life
and i think he just lost the piece there
that's it
that's it that's a full piece
king e4
oh he should have played king four i
think
knight takes there's night takes oh
oh no you can't do it it's check it's
it's time it's time it was a time
pressure but overall i was just trying
to move quickly and build up pressure i
think also because last week when i
played lavon in the uh ten plus two game
i mean i was much worse but then when he
got to about like 10 seconds he started
making some some mistakes and
inaccuracies and so i definitely had
that in the back of my mind in terms of
what i was trying to do
we have wesley playing richard here on
board four both of them with two out of
three a pretty big game that has oh
under the rock
what
that must have been a mouse slip
justin is one of the most underrated
speedsters you'll meet and he is
incredibly fast he's he's not going to
lose this game and he's actually playing
for a win now
wesley is just not experiencing these
time scrambles and he's got to be very
careful not to lose this oh i didn't
watched it what did i just say oh my god
he has difficulty he has to trade rooks
into a lost spot end game
should have taken the draw now we got to
make sure we keep the knight f5 knight
g7 but then you've got the 50 move rule
when is it no but there's i feel like
you've
you have like 20 moves left so exactly
he's gonna be he needs to be efficient
but he's got made it 11.
made in 11 he said
wow
vladimir bravo
well there's a lot of pawns it should
actually be easy to play for black right
because what do you do when you have a
lot of fun he's going to get mated you
got to push him baby
how come that pawn isn't on
[Music]
mate rook d3 oh
he saw it
unbelievable how does he do it again and
again and again he won
again
bishop k7 bishop d7
the engine likes d takes e5 after bishop
which i do personally is a surprise but
he car plays it instantly
wow
when he car is looking in the air you
know something's coming and
he doesn't even need to push a5 look at
that he doesn't even need to push this
pawn it's the threat of it that's
keeping white's king at bay and i think
lavon is going to resign right here and
right now
wow
wow and he does
what a game are you excited to show that
the older generation still has
some miles left in the tank
well you know it's funny actually wait
as i think about the candidates i might
actually wait am i the oldest player in
the field
it's like i actually am right i've never
thought about that until now oh my gosh
that's crazy
[Music]
i've never seen mate with two bishops in
a
move is stalemate oh my god this is
actually really hard yeah get the knight
out of the way
the knight is confusing
get the knight out of the way he's gonna
get it to get it to h8 oh get to the
other way he just made
going to stalemate him
he manages to win
oh man
argentarian oh me made him miss me he
mismade on a6 oh but he's gonna win by
flagging
okay he's still gonna win but that was
the we had made on a6
wait
oh my god
what's he doing
oh the rook deforex e5 or gay fiber
before
that's how you play tickle right
[Laughter]
except twist ending he's going to play
the berlin for a win
i'm just and he's got an f6 he carver
has gotten that f6 he's got knight f6
castles he took e4
oh a sacrifice
he blundered he was he blunted the
bishop he blew the bishop
oh my god but the knight is trapped on
the engine that's an amazing idea a
novelty of the year i've never seen this
before oh my god
the queens are dancing this is amazing
oh my god one number one the queen
shuffled their weight in peace oh my god
the king has to go through b5 to a4 to
b3 what is going on oh king before
oh my god
and krishna with the
wide-eyed
what
just happened he's making serious
inroads dude he found that with no time
on his clock oh my god
why did he mouse slips he mouse slips no
a mouse slipped to e4
but what anyone gosh
i don't know what he even wanted
rookie three doesn't make any sense
either oh my lance it makes no sense
fabby just lost his mind there but it
was already really bad
[Music]
i have to play on and we see falif
komalev uh taking his time here what is
he uh gonna do okay
where was queen h5 maybe possible
there's
a
[Music]
look at that
indeed anna and you gotta be careful
here to not give a stalemate as in you
uh place your pieces in such way
no
as i was saying
you jinxed it this time it wasn't me
it was you we are so good at this
we are a great team and i i have to
underpin it
went over and once the h7 pawn is gone
it is
i was gonna save this game over but it's
not oh
this is unbelievable rook h7 and if you
take on h7 there is king takes wait a
second you're not you're not taking it
you're not taking it off you cannot move
you move the rook away you get the check
the king cannot move the pawns cannot
move it is an incredible position the
punisher is smiling uh in pain a little
bit i guess there's f3
and he wants oh i see two okay 91.81
wow okay ah and there's no way to get on
e6
wait can you go king h1 and rick d6
bishop moves yeah he gets it back so
okay he asked for something like bishop
c7
wait what is bishop
oh look at him he can't believe it
after that amazing defense he just
hangs his bishop
and yonder palm she takes that bishop he
takes the game and thus this week's
rapid chess championship
[Music]
it's still on the side to carve it down
to 30 seconds oh no
he might not do that you might not be
able to do it he's down to 25. okay
oh he had to go b3
he didn't go bishop d3 there escaping
again although it can only get to a
three because b
these are under control these are under
control so you can force the king he's
fighting king a2
oh he should definitely go king a2 king
b5 oh he's back to home base
and he needs to get this way yeah yeah
he's going
he got him with a dropper he didn't do
it
oh my goodness
no debeck abducetaro continues to be the
closest thing to kryptonite that we have
seen for hikaru nakamura hey let's go 42
nice try whoa look at the primos oh
gig up two
wow this is some great pre-moving
boom
[Music]
you didn't find any other moves to make
oh that is ridiculous
and he just like laughing because
otherwise he's gonna cry menu of options
oh what wait what
rook h
oh my gosh
what a move i did it oh my god you just
turned it around
oh my what an unexpected move oh my god
i completely missed i did that didn't
even occur to me in my wildest dreams
and it's losing now because you queen
can't move
[Music]
oh
you lagged and he flagged and there it
is hikaru nakamura wins the sunday
knockout
[Music]
versus a new player haven't seen before
harsha
barata cody did i say that right
all right that was that's
cody that was really good
yeah yeah i wouldn't guys i wouldn't
have said that if i were alright
oh no
we know that's that twenty seven hundred
stuff that's your day for this queen of
two because you're gonna be ninety three
i know ninety three ninety eight one
even better
i'm out oh my god he threatens mate in
two ways back rank and g2
yo do we got a fair play on hikaru let's
get through and play team you know but
has got to be pissed on that
the bishop can't move because g2 would
have been mate and look he's not even
done being dirty oh my god this is a
little shake stick and move right
triangulation
check look at that two again
just go just go right back to the same
corner and remind white that it's still
made
yeah this is so cool
[Music]
okay you can do either one here
wait what he did oh my god
did he play rook d8 he should have
played rook d8
oh my gosh it car does it again
what in the world just happened it was
from resignation
boardng could lose this game now with
only four seconds
what is going on here
i am i am absolutely blown away how did
we get here what in the world you called
it danny you said that
because hikaru didn't lose that first
match against bortnick where he had the
losing position multiple times during
that match actually uh he was in trouble
but he saved it he recovered from it and
he wins it all toro has that effect on
players and he's a hard guy to put away
and that's why he has won yet another
rapid chess championship presented by
coinbase
[Music]
um
so fortnit though is oh gosh oh he
didn't trade the
there queens
probably winning and now i don't think
it is anymore and boarding is just
removing every single move is roosevelt
gonna flag him here two seconds for
boardnik
i mean at this rate burning's gonna flag
him oh that's okay
oh my god
but but the queen but black hang the
screen just primo primo primo primo
proof it's gonna be a draw right
yeah
simply how chess works
okay the king starts coming
but of course black can't really make
progress here so actually he has a
really nice setup where he can just
shift back and forth and back and forth
forever
um
but now fabian is putting the bishop on
d3 maybe to make sure he kind of
pre-move anymore
okay
okay now maybe you walk the king around
yeah the other thing that's important to
note so you can't move the bishop here
so when the king is on a2 if you move
the bishop away then
bishop b1 check king a1 bishop c2 is
going to win
um bishop
oh that's so good
oh my god bobby got him
what a nice maneuver yeah yeah the
bishop has to move and fabiano wins the
game
that was so clever so using the king to
block the rook
king a rook h2 here yeah but rook
takes three
what was it
yeah g5 and goes to h5 oh my goodness
but but if you've got h2 here isn't it
just to draw rook to you all right you
go rg1 is perfect rook g6 i guess also
watch out for this one little child king
of the king g7 it's over doubles gonna
lose kg7 it's game over this is insane
h2 rook g1 it's over king h6 yeah he's
going to rook b8 okay and rook do you
want rook you want it's over it's done
incredible
h1 just h1
how did that happen the mouse i guess he
mouse flipped because he wanted to go
king e5 and
amazing piece sacrificed by chris just
e4 is just crashing through in the
center and take take with the rook
premium looks over
oh my goodness
or e3 anything should be winning your e3
i think even knight g7 you know just
this piece is hanging but either i mean
what do you do against palm and grishock
what an amazing win to clinch week 16 of
the rapid chest we are joined by the
winner of the week 16 ko alexander
grishok and alexander what a day you had
how do you feel after that bullet
victory you seem like you were stressed
and then you could finally breathe for
the first time in a few hours
yeah i'm extremely happy
especially well since pandemics started
i i was struggling greatly
in cheers
okay i also had very bad moods for two
because of this
everything connected with pandemic with
the masks
yeah i'm extremely happy actually just
extremely and you know what that like
around one month ago i said to my wife
that
basically i have two
ambitions left in chess is to win title
tuesday and this
weekend wrap it
and basically if i win it i can retire
with clear countries
but you know what
i won and now i don't want to retire
[Music]
knight f4 there's rookie through china
oh
forcing the king back king g2
another repetition is possible
give me the point
are you losing both in a row that means
that white can't lose
yeah you could just take g3 done
oh f5 oh
queen f6 queen f6 wait queen e4 i guess
there has to be eight okay wait a minute
maybe queen or any no no no
oh roxy fo
he's just seen everything he really is
and now knight e2 king h2 and he carves
can you wait uh
can you take on g3 in that position
that's maybe the
most clear-cut oh you just blast through
the entire the gates on the king's side
right
i don't know actually anything
oh
wait
g4 fg there's nothing yeah and then hg i
play rook takes g4 because not king
takes two four because then you take
with check and hikar is going to lose
wow
and a fist bump from jewel massage
betrays a smile and that was one of the
most unbelievable matches we've seen in
a long time in the rcc
okay
one by jules and okay again he played
pretty quickly there and e2 ends the
game straight up he does he's too roxy
too oh wait no it doesn't no it doesn't
no it doesn't no it doesn't okay he won
oh my god am i loose
oh my god
but thankfully
thankfully uh he doesn't stumble on
with these three still trying
yeah he he should probably he should
play until mate like you said yeah yeah
for sure i mean ah but he does very
gracious yeah it is it is gracious
though
very gracious by jules but dimitri and
draken surviving an internet scare
and winning in style
he wins yet another weekend of the rcc
what a beast demetrian dragon is
[Music]
ooh f5
i remember naka once played this f5
against me in like a really bad position
it was like a 960 game and
he's basically like getting mated but he
plays that fight
everything is open and then i couldn't i
couldn't figure it out
but oh man port nick with the fist pump
okay
oh no it's not going to work for black
man on a1 is two the knight on c2 is too
good e3 is a nice hope but there's rook
a3
boy throws another check knight e3 he
covers the pawn on the light square
david it's all over
yeah bach knows that he's going to
resign
unbelievable time scramble look at
wesley so
so relieved dang
i mean with 30 seconds this is
nerve-wracking for me costa i would not
want to do this with two seconds this is
very hard for white now i mean like
white spawn's under control white has to
make sure he doesn't allow it there we
go the king d1 there king d1 could have
been winning on the spot
again king d1 again and he finds it this
time
he finds it this time dubois is upset
just give the check that's it wow he
blew it he allowed this king d1 multiple
times
and that's it his king is not getting to
the g pawn black is taking it and
praveen
wins the game
rookie four own finds it
dude he doesn't see a move he's got six
seconds i don't see it either
and he allows me to win
oh no wow hikaru he just finds the trick
there unbelievable yeah
i don't know i mean i'm i'm pretty one
equals
promote to a knight and then there might
be some way to go oh my gosh
in the last position promote to a knight
and white plays king age three maybe
that's what fetish was trying to make
bishops
he messed up the auto queen maybe he's
trying to
promote yeah
and couldn't get control over that
yeah you just got to hit alt guys public
service announcement you hit alt and
then he gives you the option oh boy oh
man this and naka i think he can just
like shuffle back and forth like i mean
obviously he's gonna find good moves
here but he's
just like
you can just chill i mean how long can
you play on four seconds
we're about to find out let's see wesley
kick into that other gear he had that
other gear he had he wouldn't have
needed his first 50 seconds
right
now another pair of knights no
oh he flagged oh no
wesley
[Music]
since the time situation has equalized
oh and now but it's winning apparently
yeah knight c4 uh-huh 197. you know
that was a bad decision for him we had
to go knight
oh rook takes e3 movement wow
is he queening that pawn oh my god vin
it's so slow here
wow
this is crazy
oh king b5 black wins
wow wow did you see that if white had
promoted black would have taken the
knight and skewered the queen yeah yeah
who's gonna win the game
it's gonna flag black still is
wow
wow he's going for the win
but he's going to lose what is he doing
he wants to flag him but he's going to
get checkmated
we know he's wait uh yeah fabi is black
right okay so bobby's black so he's not
doing this i don't know but can he hold
this position king b7 he's got to make
sure to trade the queens otherwise he's
going to get mated
oh
man oh he seems so upset look at him oh
my god oh man i would be upset too if i
did that bobby i feel for you i think he
might have mouse slipped bishop g6 i'm
not sure maybe
oh the knight hangs
c6
so passive now all the black pieces
look at this total devastation bishop f7
though knight f6 check oh goodbye
rookie mate bang be you would have fully
done by sam sevien why is this winning
oh and he just wants to go through he's
going around king d2 is he in zugsvang
bishop
e8 and bishop h5 and if he can try to
get white and zucchini i don't see it
yet
king e3 oh
bishop takes he takes it
wait is this winning takes takes king of
2k
it is winning takes in g6
no
yes
yes no i got it king e2 king g2 and g4
you give up one of your pawns you fix
the other one on g5 and you induce
bomb oh my will he play it he doesn't
even need to do it it's over samuel
sebian is gonna win this game
this is unbelievable
wrong way wesley should have gone to g6
four seconds king g4 why did he do that
he was in zugsvan oh my god
oh why did he just take the pawn oh my
god oh he blinded the knight he blew up
the knife
oh my
wesley smiling savion shaking his head
the same coin but two very different
sides of it goodness me this game it had
it all
a unique online event with enticing high
stakes the inaugural season of the rapid
chess championship delivered its fair
share of big names and big moments andy
karu nakamura is going to win how did he
do that
with more than 50 grand masters claiming
cash prizes over six months of weekly
competition it was also home to a
healthy helping of big surprises e6
wandering up seven this has been such a
roller coaster awarding over half a
million dollars in cash money
but year one of the rcc is not done yet
the rapid chess championship is
presented by coinbase and the finals are
finally here
the brightest stars from the regular
season including hikaru nakamura fabiano
caruana alexander grisham and more are
back to take a run at a fresh 150
thousand dollars and the very first
rapid chess championship title
also in the mix the familiar faces of
top players known for dominating elite
online chess events how will they handle
the pressure of chasing a championship
and crashing this party as wildcard
invites some of the most famous names in
competitive chess drop in to stake their
claim to the 30 thousand dollar first
prize
[Music]
my friends
it's the inaugural rapid chess
championship final who will make history
as our first rcc champion what surprises
are still to come
we are soon to find out
welcome to championship sunday here at
the rapid chess championship presented
by coinbase i'm grand master robert hess
alongside me today as always grand
master daniel naraditsky donya we're at
our final four players yonder pomschi
has a leg up on the competition he can
lose two matches on route to a
championship here at the rapid chess
championship but three players wesley
soh dimitri andreikin hikaru nakamura
they're looking to unseat yonder ponchi
and win the crown
and let me repeat that in order to win
the rcc one of those three players is
going to have to beat yon napomnishi
twice
and beat yada pognashi and twice
they don't go very well together so
they've got their work cut out for them
jan has been on an absolute tear and i
am
so excited to see whether jan will
continue his absolute dominance over
online and over-the-board chess today
he has been phenomenal indeed let's
remind everyone of the format here and
the finals we started with 16 players 12
from the rapid chess championship series
those grand prix points were accumulated
and 12 players made the field from that
four other players including yonda
pomshi were invited directly into the
field it's a double elimination bracket
the matches are two games of ten minute
plus two second increment and if it's
tied one-to-one we get the beloved
armageddon format with bidding we had a
lot of fun with that yesterday
fun for some players more than others
but still we like that in the prize
fundania it's massive and we only have
four spots remaining so the players know
that at minimum you're getting 13 000
yeah and they are of course looking at
that 30 000
prize they have taken out their car
loans
and they have gathered together the down
payments this is an incredibly generous
price but uh the bigger prize and we all
know this
is the fact that the winner
uh
of the rapid chess championship is it
has a certain ring to it let's put it
that way
yeah rcc champ i like the sound of that
and i think every player remaining in
the field whether it's demetrion draken
wesley so hikaru nakamura yon napomshi
they're vying for that crown first and
foremost but the 30 thousand dollars not
a bad payday indeed and it wouldn't be
possible without our presenting sponsor
and no better person to give them a
shout out coinbase than our chief chief
chess officer danny wrench
the rapid chess championship is brought
to you by coinbase whether you're
looking to make your first crypto
purchase or you're an experienced trader
coinbase has you covered you can earn
crypto by learning about crypto at
coinbase.com explore d5 and web3 with
your coinbase wallet get exclusive
rewards when you spend with your
coinbase card and much much more learn
more at coinbase.com
and get 10 in bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account check them out
use the command sponsor or command
coinbase today and go to coinbase.com to
get that bitcoin baby
these are our four remaining contestants
donya and let's start with wesley so we
see him all the way in the left-hand
side of the screen and as is usually the
case in online chess it seems like the
only player who could take him down is
ikar nakamura
yeah and we saw that yesterday wesley
deconstructing
dingley wren
and he is just a force to be reckoned
with he proves once again that he is
among the most consistent players online
we we saw that week in and week out in
the regular season of the rcc we are
seeing that
uh once again here
but yukari nakamura he is wesley so's
kryptonite and he is everybody's
kryptonite so wesley
i mean he can hold a setup high he
certainly can he is a matching dimitri
on draken who as we discussed yesterday
time and time again the guy is
overlooked and yet here he is as one of
the final four players in the raptor
chess championship
yeah we were talking about it at length
yesterday dimitri's over 2700 feet day
he's not some run-of-the-mill
grandmaster who happens to be good at
rapid he is someone with a tremendous
over-the-board pedigree phenomenal
opening repertoire great positional
skill and nobody likes playing him i've
never come across a person who excitedly
said i am playing grandmaster feature
and draken today it's gonna be an easy
certainly not the case and hikaru
nakamura whether he plays wesley or on
draken he knows he's in for a tough
battle on draken has won many many title
tuesday events wesley so has won the
grand chess tour among many other
top-level events including the u.s chess
championship numerous times so yonder
palm shield at the end of the day he'll
await the winner of the losers bracket
not every day danya where we use the
words losers bracket in hikaru nakamura
though
yeah
i mentioned that yana pandey she beat
twice don't mix very well uh hikaru
nakamura and losers bracket don't mix uh
very well either
certainly do not but as we've been
talking about dimitri let's bring him up
for a hired player resume we've had him
on screen a number of times that's
because he's outlasting much of the
competition he is a two-time russian
champion and donya if people know
anything about the chess world winning
the russian championship
once and then twice come on that is a
superstar
yeah that's an absolute impossible task
you have to surmount
an unbelievable amount of super gms and
draken's pedigree precedes him his
second place finish in the rcc regular
season
uh was somewhat overshadowed by hikaru's
absolute mastery but let us not forget
how consistent and how masterful he is
just day in and day out he is superb and
this is his player resume but
time to give a shout out to our great
partners in hired if you're tired of
cover letters applications and hidden
salary ranges in tech hired powers
software engineers to manage their own
hiring path with a marketplace of over
ten thousand employers worldwide hired
candidates experience managers will help
you navigate incoming employer interview
requests giving you back the control to
land the tech job you'll love what's not
to love create your free hired profile
today well donya we have just one minute
remaining until the action kicks off it
is wesley so it is demetrion draken and
i think a talking point that we actually
have forgotten to mention is andreikin
did superbly in the grand prix in the
theater grand prix where he scored
believed 10 points in the first grand
prix that he didn't play in the final
stage where he would have been the same
group as lebron ironian and icard
nakamura that's how hikaru made his way
to candidates on draken he was right up
there with the best of them so
his online chess success also translates
over the board but today it's all about
this rapid time control and right now
it's about beating western south yeah
it's one of those matchups where you
have an immovable object against an
unstoppable force both of these players
are incredibly solid we we did see
wesley
very uncharacteristically lose the
threat of the game against
icarus and he's got to make sure that
that doesn't happen again but when
wesley gets his type of position he's an
absolute buzz up
that's great with that it's a great way
of describing him because he just will
rip your position to shreds i mean the
way wesley so wins game is like i don't
really know sometimes where his
opponents go wrong but demetrion draken
plays in the same vein he is the type of
player who yes like he did to fog under
caruana in their first game he'll just
tear your position apart tactically if
you give him the opportunity but he's
much more of an end game aficionado
where he'll outlast you
pawn up grind you down and score that
full point
yeah i think of their playing styles as
kind of a uh one of those spiky cogs
that keeps turning and turning when you
throw something at it it just completely
you know it disassembles you
and by the time you're done with lester
so you have not a single connected pawn
chain left in your position your king is
wide open you're down material and both
of these players are
exactly like that so when they face off
against each other we always get very
exciting games
and on draken you know he's looking
pretty calm right now wesley so he has
been very demonstrative after his match
victories right he's hands are in the
air fist pumping yeah so it means a lot
to him yeah it has been and now the game
is underway we see that the move knight
f3 played by andreikin d5 the standard
choice by wesley so so
i guess as we get into this match before
we see any results we do need to ask a
question to the chat because we want you
to get involved so with the game
starting coinbase wants to hear from you
who will be our first rapid chess
champion you have four people to choose
from
make your choice is not one of them no
no no he is gladly off the list
that's a real shame i don't want zero
percent of the vote you know
in the meantime we have
a pretty interesting opening dimitra and
draken going off the beaten path of this
move c2 c3 now c4 robert leads to
a very topical line of the grunfeld c3
is a move that was previously championed
by vladimir kramnik it is often followed
oddly enough by queenside expansion a4
there it is
and you just get a position
yeah
and i mean when we look at this and on
drinking with the white pieces he
probably doesn't want to test
wesley in prep
long lines of preparation he wants to
just get a position where he's
comfortable with and this is exactly one
of those look at this position you can
put a5 for white you can play knight e5
you have options here so it's not like
you have to stick to just a single plan
but knight e5 does seem to be a
principled approach with a5 to follow
yeah putting putting together some early
queen side pressure
uh i don't really see a downside to
starting with the move a5 i mean knight
e5 seems a little bit more committal
uh but starting with a5 looks
perfectly
[Music]
perfectly reasonable now one thing to
decide for black is where to put the
light squid bishop because the hyper
fianchetto bishop c8 to a6 actually
makes more sense to me here than the
more conventional uh development uh to
b7 robert do you are you on the same
page about this yeah it's a more open
diagonal bishop b7 you like to say this
down yet bad bishops defend good pawns
and it's protecting that great pawn on
d5 but bishop a6 it shuts down the a
file it doesn't allow white to thrust
that pawn forward to a6 himself and that
was wesley so's choice good call dania
just as i was making the move he played
it
just grabbed that bishop right from your
hand right
so rude honestly wesley is i mean like
very consistent with his overall pattern
of behavior
[Laughter]
yeah not uh one of the most humble
people on the facebook no no definitely
not constantly bragging about his
achievements how well he did in the rcc
even tweeting about it constantly
so so drake now has to decide where to
put these two pieces now bishop f4 is
the standard
uh development of the bishop in such
positions as far as i know
yes 85. i was going to quickly say donut
that a lot of players would take on b6
immediately because they want to open up
the rook on a1 but that tension is not
going anywhere in fact the tension
favors white because look at the rook on
a8 it stares into its own pawn whereas
white's rook has much more space on this
file for the moment so why give black
access to that same line
yeah white is the one who knocks on the
a file
and black is not about to go b6 b5 and
create a gaping hole on c5 no
no no no that bishop on a6 that we were
just praising would be terrible all of a
sudden with a pawn directly in front of
it so
c5 is a much more likely play from
wesley's perspective and i don't easily
see a plan for dimitri okay knight b to
d2 it feels like not
the london system exactly but just like
in the london system sometimes you put
all your pieces on perfect squares and
then the question becomes what now so
diana what are you seeing from dimitri's
perspective what does he like about his
position
well he likes the fact that he has more
space on the queen side he likes the
fact that wesley is you know somewhat
cramped and tied down on the queen side
and dimitri controls some of the dark
squares uh particularly if wesley plays
the move c5 but this is a very familiar
situation to me where
i
you realize that this moment will occur
about two or three moments before it
actually does you're like i still have a
couple developing moves left but very
soon i'm gonna be in a situation where
i'm gonna have no idea what to do and
i am
much like you worried that after wesley
plays c5 dmitry will reach that moment
when you've made all the developing
moves you've dotted your eyes and
crossed your t's
what do you have to show for it i mean
you can't win a game with the space
advantage maybe one
are you gonna go e4 is that your i'm
thinking about flirting with it i guess
you also allow your queen to move so
rookie one is sort of dual purpose you
may push that pawn but at the very least
you protected the pawn e2 and that way
your queen can go out to a square like
a4 and maybe there are places to
infiltrate from there another idea that
i have done is maybe i don't know if it
works can i throw in a bishop d6 first
and then play knight e5 or right you can
get my bishop trap
well yeah you're basically you know
telling your minor pieces to go handle
themselves and whatever happens happens
you're on your own now
yeah
just deal with the consequences it's not
my responsibility but it's not easy to
access that bishop on d6 because if the
knight on d7 moves away then the c5 pawn
hangs right
so it's definitely an interesting idea
okay well rookie 8 takes the sting out
of bishop b6 so now that would be a
pretty nonsense move so all right
we've reached
everything that we could have possibly
asked for is it time for e4 are there
other moves to make like a queen move
you can play h3 or even h4 if you feel
like you can always play h3
there's always that
and then wesley will play h6
and then maybe g4 and then maybe g5
right
bishop g3
king h8 there's little moves here and
there and when in doubt start playing on
the king's side
there we finally see it the knight jumps
forward and
well
black i guess doesn't want to take on e5
not because of d takes e but bishop
takes e5 feels a little bit annoying
over there so
can i make a different move for that
knight h5 here for black
yeah knight h5 looks pretty pesky
actually
wait a moment knight h5
what is white going to do because if
white plays knight takes d7 there's no
problem i'm just gonna move my bishop
back no no no black's going to take on
f4 first right
and this is not a positive
transformation
of the structure for white black is
better here
the bishop pair the healthier pawn
structure and thereby the safer king if
you want to look at it that way the
knight on d2 not in the game so i think
dimitri overlooked knight h5 and daniel
from an early stage oh white is
comfortable safe but look at dimitri's
clock by the way he has never found a
plane in this game he's making logical
moves but without an actual overarching
plan and now wesley well ahead of the
clock and i think his position is better
yeah dimitri has to find a way to
twist himself out of this position there
is this weird idea of going bishop
uh you can do that immediately you can
do that here and after queen takes g5
knight 67 you're attacking b6
but wesley can just drop the queen back
to d8 force the knight back to e5 and
say
hey i've got the two bishops i'm happy
yeah although at least the pawn
structure isn't compromised from
dimitri's perspective but of course
wesley is better in this position so
dimitri look at him he just actually he
raised his eyebrows oops didn't see this
one coming this is just as great of a
position as you could possibly ask for
from wesley so's perspective and it's a
good sign if you're a wesley fan
yeah and this is just what he does he
never beats himself
he he's so consistent he plays healthy
moves and he just makes you look like
not like a fool that's the wrong word
but when you're playing wesley you know
you just don't feel good about your
position no matter what position you
have did you see by the way that wesley
pre-moved eight takes b6 yeah that's a
badass move right there yeah it's like
not only is he just one of the best
chess players in the world given each
player hours he's saying i actually know
how to play bullet chest with the best
one and he does and he pre-moved a takes
b6 to put dimitri right back on the
clock he crushed me in a blitz match
yesterday he was incredible
he beat me he was incredibly fast yeah
and he pre-moves he knows how to time
scramble he doesn't have any obvious
achilles heels
as a blitz player no he doesn't i mean
he really has that style that uh as
you're saying you don't want to play
dimitri on draken you also don't really
want to play wesley so and right now i
think dimitri is the less happy of the
two and wes is up four minutes on the
clock
we're talking we're shooting the breeze
in the meantime dimitri's under four
minutes i've been thinking about queen
a4 here
but
that is
obviously not a movie make if you're
enthralled to their position
i'm just trying to find some way to
resolve the tension in the center yeah
queen a4 is a way to do that but i think
black will still take the bishop on f4
and then deal with uh the knights aiming
at each other after that so yeah i guess
you can just take
yeah that's not serious well knight d7
is played and now knight takes f4 seems
automatic or is there a difference not
the pawns have been traded no i don't
think so
no i think you take because knight takes
b6 there's always knight takes e2 check
right so dimitri's gonna play e3
you know what's funny about positions
like this donya i always feel like okay
black has to be better and then i look
at this bishop on g7 and i look at all
of white's pawns on dark squares and
like do i really have the advantage when
my bishop is blockaded by these pawns so
the answer the solution might be to play
cd4 at some point in bishop f8 to
improve uh the scope of your bishop
that's actually a great positional idea
and
would you consider doing it immediately
just right here and right now c takes d4
i'm a little nervous to release the
tension we've been talking about that a
lot throughout the days of commentary
here and so
wesley says no let me let me keep that
alive and
does this give demetri an opportunity in
any way that's what in knight f3 95
you're playing queen a4 as well
yeah queen 84 could be a little bit
annoying for black because it limits the
scope of this bishop you don't want to
go bishop d3 you don't want to give away
the two rooks for the queen definitely
not
especially because white will have total
domination over the only open file
right and actually if you put bishop b7
queen b5 seems right really annoying to
me
and there's all sorts of tactical
shenanigans that might
negatively impact black's chances here
for example if we extend that line after
queen c6 white can take and drop a
knight on c4
and before you know it you're under a
lot of pressure upon b6 is a
full-fledged weakness no that's actually
a frustrating line and once you see it
you realize that a queen trade may sound
good but it's not getting you much so b5
go ahead is wesley's choice it is
definitely a good move but one major
drawback of this is if dimitri can play
knight b3 his knight might land on c5
and then you regret the fact that your
pawn is no longer on v6 for sure so
wesley will have to follow this up
very accurately in this position maybe
c4
a c4
could be met by b4 to if dmitry really
wants to close things up
it's weird to have your queen on it is
almost strapped there man
it's gonna evacuate to a2
right and the bishop can't go to b7
which would trap the queen if the pawn
on b5 was defended so that's the big
problem for black is the bishop stuck
there i think with that head shake there
and now with some time consumption
wesley not thrilled i think he believed
he would have a bigger or more clear
advantage but dimitri he is just a
frustrating player
he's just annoying
i mean he just knows how to get under
your skin in any position
right and the knight might get under
black skin of knight b3 to c5
so knight p3 what does wesley have under
his sleeve
uh he better show us real quick because
i'm actually starting to get worried
about his position
yeah once the knight hits c5 you might
lose this pawn
and if you lose this pawn then the
position starts to crumble wait a minute
c4
no you don't have bishop b7 after knight
c5 there's a cool line
after c4 knight c5 bishop b7 it's a
totally moot point because white can
just play knight takes b7 for sure and
then the queen on decision
exactly
yes
[Laughter]
so there is something long term we
should talk about if we look at
white's pawn structure all of these
pawns are on dark squares so if c4 and
later b4 things like that even with
opposite colored bishops it could still
be dangerous for white because these
pawns can be attacked by a black's
bishop
black's pawns on the other hand the pawn
chain is as strong as his base pawn good
luck getting to the pawn on f7 i mean
that's untouchable
that's a great point but
i mean wesley's dreaming of such an
endgame
yeah he is a little bit far away from it
so c takes d4
seems to me more more logistically
doable than c4
right so cdcd of course we're not going
to take with the e pawn to make our f4
pawn
loose
so
no again before knight c5 jeez
you know what might be the best thing to
do is play cd4 cd4 and bishop b7 give up
your b5 pawn and just try to get
activity because the bishop on a6 is a
truly terrible piece and it's also
making your other pieces worse because
you're tied down to its defense
i also think he does have a way to bail
out this line i mentioned to you earlier
c5 c4 and bishop b7 i abandoned hope
quickly but i actually think this might
be the most prudent option
if we bring up the analysis board here
queen takes b5 bishop c6 i think traps
the queen believe it or not and
but the most important things white
cannot get two rooks for the queen
because the bishop defends a a now i
pointed out that white as knight takes
b7 he absolutely does but
you your point i think is very well
taken here black is most certainly not
worse if i had to choose a side i would
actually probably take black despite the
fact that white holds ownership over the
a file right and that that's this is the
exact type of position i was fortunate
so thanks for bringing it to the board
here for us and c4 is wesley's gonna
bring it to the board
okay
and after knight c5 do you have any
other choice besides playing bishop b7
because your bishop's just under attack
over there on a6 i guess rook a7 is a
move but ooh
but then knight a6 and b5 falls so
right
but at least black controls the a file
you're right you're not we're saying at
least i have this
after dropping something to hang my hat
on oh
that's super clever
knight a6 is met by rook b6 now
typical wesley idea right
he says i want your rook a7 to team up
on the 986 but this is a better way of
doing so because b5 remains protected
so
if dimitri doesn't take what is wesley's
next move is it going to be
bishop e7
maybe or something bishop or
possibly
i say with no degree of confidence oh my
force oh god we are in for a fart burner
here
just added a load of tabasco
position he just wants to open this
position up because look at that work on
a8 and there's a bishop on g2 that's
been waiting in the shadows ready to
pounce at the right moment after de4
bishop takes e4 i guess bishop b7 is
still possible down here oh my god
i was not expecting to do this kind of
calculation at this at this hour
bishop before bishop b7 knight b7
then just take the queen on a5
and then there's a fizzle out and upon
f4 is a
huge liability in that resulting end
game and once black takes it the bishop
has a direct pathway to c1
yeah this seems like wesley somehow got
the best of all worlds here the end game
we were
highlighting as possible and now it's
even with the worst poncho so dimitri
thinking which means he might take on e4
with the knight but then i think wesley
can get his uh
his
his claws out and steal f4 and then what
does dimitri have to show for it i think
dimitri largely played e4 on an
intuitive basis i don't think that he
calculated it too deeply
and now bishop b7
very nasty move and dimitri will just
have to try to make a draw in that
opposite colored bishop end game
okay so knight takes b7 looks forced to
my eyes
it is
so what's dimitri thinking about i guess
there's no other move here
that's a good question every second is
golden this end game is not going to be
easy to defend here's the mass trade
rook
yeah that's what i was about to ask you
is rookie just forced to draw because it
doesn't do that just just go for it
right
i think it does i think it does
i think it does rook a8 if we very
quickly play through the moves takes
takes takes
bishop c6 and you eat up these two pawns
just in time you're gonna be down a pawn
in the resulting position but i'm pretty
sure white can hold that
dimitri though choosing a different
approach
and probably an even more accurate one
going for active defense with d5 yes so
kind of a similar idea that he
ultimately wants to start trading pawn
so even if he loses the f4 pawn as long
as the queen side comes off completely
it's just a complete another draw when
you're down upon opposite-colored
bishops pawns on the same side of the
board uh the
side with the extra material is not
going to win so he's going for rook a8
or he could put his work on a7 if the
bishop lands on d5 and that way f7 is a
target so i think that dimitri has this
handled quite nicely yeah i wouldn't say
that this is a three result game but
you know if wesley does something
untoward
you could end up dropping a bunch of
pawns here in the blink of an eye
right like for example rook f8 i believe
is a mistake because then b7 happens and
you drop b5 which protects b2 and then
c4 is likely to fall next and that's how
you lose games like this oh exactly
exactly you you lose them by playing a
reactive move you know oh f7 saying
let's defend it that's not how these end
games work you need to strategically
choose which pawns to give away i think
wesley's gonna go bishop c1 something to
that effect this is just a draw yeah
rook upset
by dimitri by the way no that was
composure perfectly executed there and
also good composition by wesley because
it seemed like he overlooked this like
queen a5 knight b3 type of maneuver but
instead of freaking out and uh causing
himself some unnecessary issues he's
just like you know what i have the black
pieces let's just make sure that
everything remains solid that i uh can
make a draw at the lease and here we see
every pawn is about to be traded if the
rooks are swapped b2 falls first but
after bishop a6 b5 and c4 will fall
right next yeah it's so interesting
black actually takes both of white's
pawns first
but then dwight instantly takes both of
black spawns
yes and and
forthcoming we often see this in
opposite colored bishop endings and
well what's was wesley really thinking
or is he just trying to gather his
bearings to
you know figure out what he can do with
the white pieces
well he's either yeah exactly he's
taking the bonus time
uh to to think about the opening in the
next game maybe he's
reviewing this game in his head which
you sometimes see players do they're
looking at their score sheets
trying to identify
where the improvements were but
takes on c3 accompanies it with a
drawfur which is
dutifully accepted
you know hey the final position donya
and the result that does not tell you
the full story of that game i i would
thought dimitri and draken had a shaky
position early on with a knight h5 move
hit him by surprise and then he played
pretty much perfectly after that he just
got that activity with his e4 push he
traded the pieces as was necessary so i
would say that wesley should be the
happier of the two but dimitri he can
count on his chest kills because he
showed some class there
he certainly did and his form has
improved just exponentially ever since
that nightmare first day remember he
blundered
two pieces in succession
and now here he is putting together
flawless defensive effort against wesley
so but he needs to bring his a plus game
with the black pieces and i'm very
curious to know what opening he will
choose will he play a sicilian or will
he stick to something more solid i think
the problem with what you said not your
words but what they indicate is that you
said defensive effort when the white
pieces you don't want to be on the
defensive you don't and especially not
against uh top player who oh dimitri's
tell you what wait did you see he
doesn't want to be in the defense of the
black pieces but you see his one bar of
connection right now dimitri was the
beneficiary of some uh untimely
disconnection from five minute carwana
yesterday but right now it's his
internet that needs to be stabilized
yeah hopefully everything turns out
decently i mean wesley has also
experienced some issues
so we hope that that will not be the
decisive factor in this game early g3
even before knight c3
that is
strange to me because can't block just
like d5 now
i mean i think so right like you
normally that's what my mama taught me
that you just stop stop d5 that's why
you play knight t3 you know
right i i have not seen this particular
position before but wesley who did spend
12 seconds on that move
either he's bluffing and he's just
playing a random line or he has
something up his sleeve
kind of reminds me of that fetish save
bishop e3 move in the sense of guitar i
don't really believe it but on draken
did
yeah but now wesley got the exact
position you want not that this is bad
for andreikin but it felt like andrea
could have punished wesley's move order
by striking in the center
for sure and h5 is a very fashionable
move
in in this variation
and as well as everywhere else by the
way yes
and and i think that a lot of players
they react immediately you play 85 i
have to play h4 i cannot let you push
that pawn and open up your rook on aj
but look at wesley wesley yeah he says
come at me bro like what are you doing
you have no pieces over there so you're
spending all this time just to get a
fake attack and i'm just gonna continue
developing maybe i play knight c3 here
maybe i go rookie one but there is no
actual attack for black
not until black gets let's say a queen
to the h file that's much easier said
than done now one very typical idea here
you mentioned the move ricky one is to
stick a knight on d5 eventually and if
black continues to neglect his
development
it's going to be a question of when
uh rather than whether the sacrifice
occurs
yes and then you have to weather a storm
because the attack is coming in full
force so
for black it's a question how to develop
your pieces you can't play a move like
b5 right now you're not developed so
the bishop on that f8 not really seeing
where that goes so maybe knight g8
should get out of there first and maybe
it's knight g to e7 that's actually a
common idea he instead closes in his
bishop a classical approach here in
sicilian but danya it's like he wants
his cake and he wants to eat it too i
literally was about to say that phrase
yeah like he's he wants the classical
sicilian but then he's also played h5h4
i i literally was about to use that
exact phrase i was going to say once he
wants h5h4 and he wants a sicilian and
he wants development something's got to
give
right something's gotta give and what's
giving is the fact that he's lacking in
development now can wesley exploit that
so
generally the machinery
that you put in motion is rookie one and
knight d5 that's what i was taught you
could also take on c6 and play e5 but
that works a lot better when there's a
knight on f6 if white does that here
black simply plays d5 and black is very
happy to close the center
actually i think you can just put that
on the board just so we can just show
knight takes c6 bounces e5 if there were
a knight on f6 then black would have to
react to this dual threat but without
the knight there as you're saying you
can just play d5 and close the position
down and look at what wesley has done so
he does capture and plays knight a4
which is a good idea because you want to
play c2 to c4 and you're gaining space
the queen said and don't discount e5
even if it doesn't attack a knight on f6
sometimes you actually want your
opponent's pawn to go to d5 so you can
take over all the dark squares in the
queen side
no this is
responding to
and draken's sort of weirdly
classical kind of ambivalent approach
with just a centrally based positionally
minded
idea knight a4 and c4 the trojan would
be proud of that the old soviet masters
would be proud
of this treatment of the position by
wesley oh he's playing perfectly because
now there's no d5 all of white's pawns
and pieces staring at that square and
here bishop g5 is available
you might actually force black to take
on g3 and no westie says brute force is
my plan of action i'm just trying to
ruin your pawn structure
yes sticking a needle
right in the heart of black center
and dimitri bishop c8 to g4
i mean this does not look like standard
sicilian development look at this
position
i mean the fact that the bar is at zeros
or even actually says slightly better
for black okay i'm going to ignore that
for the moment this looks terrible for
black right the one thing that dimitri
has going for him is that this pawn is
on h4 which means that at some point if
wesley is not careful h takes g3 bishop
h3 now we can see how the attack rages
on but i don't really believe in the
attack i think that strategically
black's in big trouble so if he cannot
solve his problems tactically then he is
not going to have fun
and i have a far more mundane concern
which is that black's king cannot stay
in the center forever eventually and
this might actually happen on the next
move the center is going to open up so
i think and draken's top priority here
should be to find a haven for his king
whether it's on f8
or on g8 but
i might be more concerned about black's
king than white's king
right and what's fascinating is h takes
g3 was somehow a mistake you see the
eval bar immediately go up uh quite a
bit three might have been the move but i
mean that like if you think about it
like if we just can show this h3 bishop
h1 is like what did you really gain you
have no attack anymore zero and now your
pawn structure is getting ruined you're
gonna have the c6 pawn that's gonna be
targeted like doesn't that just feel
counter-intuitive to play h3 here that's
a sunk cost right you've sunk three
tempe into those pawn moves and what do
you have to show for a dried up king
side you're absolutely right it is very
hard to go for that
but now i think black's position is
genuinely miserable
right because can't you just take on d6
no you want to take with the queen on d6
but otherwise the c6 pawn drops with
check but maybe that's the best thing
that dimitri can do here is like take on
d6 to the bishop and after the check
just move his king and say i have this
attack that i'm putting in air quotes
no there's no way he's taking the queen
no way
no way dimitri is going for that
so bishop d6 queen c6 check is the king
is going up to e7
i believe it is
and i don't think wesley's going to take
on c6 i think wesley's going to make a
developing move such as bishop e3 and
say hey
you know i can essentially take this
pawn at my leisure
go defend it go waste another tempo
playing rook b8 to c8
and what you said is such good coaching
advice honestly that so many players
they say oh yummy free pawn with check
let me grab that but you're spending
time
with your queen again you're not
finishing your development so well on
the other hand dimitri takes with the
queen just to defend that pawn but i
think bishop but bishop e3 is like
white's ideas that you were just talking
about are even more obvious because
black is not developed
and
okay so the queen is obviously
stuck in the middle of an intersection
and
it can move to the side it can move to
e6 but wesley could then even consider
pushing his f button and i know that
sounds crazy because your king is on g1
but you have a bishop on e3 you have a
defensive cocoon around your king your
minor pieces can handle it your pawns
can be repurposed as attackers rather
than as
uh defenders of the king right the best
definitely giving dimitri pause right
now oh for sure and the best way to
avoid getting checkmated is by
checkmating your opponent first so
i completely get you and i think that
strategically and i don't even think i'm
stating something that's crazy here i
think strategically black is lost right
like if the status quo continues here
dmitry's just going to lose this game
because he's got split pawns on the
queen side that weston can easily target
and he hasn't finished his development
and his king is in the center so
everything possible is kind of going
wrong for on draken right now this
should be seven though that's probably
the lesser evil
because
his priority is still
to castle i think once he does that
it's going to be a little bit easier for
him to
uh
to reapportion his resources and try to
defend his queen side but i mean you can
see the evil bar it's not it's not lying
i think plus two is a pretty accurate
assessment of this position right now
and if you think about castling here for
black which he might have to do at some
point we'll see
hassling but the thing about this is you
put h5 h4
and then you castle so you have given up
on your attack and you gave white all
these tempe because unless they ignored
all that stuff that shows the plan was
not properly executed
such an instructive moment when wesley
castled honestly on move seven so few
people would have done that
and and look look how it's paid off he's
got these three extra tempe on them
now queen takes c6
is it grab time
um
i'm worried about bishop d7 at the end
of some of those lines and
that's why of course wesley you can
always count on wesley to make these
improving with b3 now you don't have to
worry about your b2 pawn your knight on
a4 is defended in many of these
variations where you do take on c6 now
wesley is just playing this game
marvelously
yeah it's been absolutely exquisite
b3
he's enjoying his life he's up three
minutes on the clock dimitron draken is
in mortal danger here and i'm trying to
think of a way that demetri can even
survive
you could put your rook on ca just to
defend this pawn but it looks such a
miserable defense here uh bishop c5 at
any moment just to
trade queens and rook d instead is
giving up this pawn
yeah i remember that meat grinder that
cog is starting to spin and black's
position is starting to come apart at
the seams but i see why he's doing this
can we just show queen c6 a queen swap
and bishop d7 again you cannot take a6
because of bishop b5 hitting both rooks
ooh
that's definitely
a sleek tactical detail you also can't
drop back to c4 in order to defend you
right for the same exact reason
so
the challenge for wesley is indeed to
choose the right moment to take on c6
you don't want to overstate your welcome
but you don't want to grab too early
either
so maybe rook fe1
not sure i like your your idea before of
pushing the f bump button one square
rather than two play f3 then rook f to
d1 then maybe bishop f1 to go after the
a6 pawn we can just target that queen
side white's king is never going to be
attacked
yeah
no it's you can
you know basically disassemble your
defensive fort here and
repurpose the pieces
uh the bishop on g2 did a great job as a
defender but now it can function
primarily as an attacker of the a6 pawn
and
wesley he's taking his time here which
is the smart thing to do because he's
really calculating queen takes c6 maybe
i don't win the second pawn a6 but it
still could be worth it to grab that
pawn or am i giving dimitri unnecessary
counter play and top level gms i think
you could back me up on this down yeah
they would prefer to be down upon with
the activity then have even material and
then be suffering for squares and that's
always true that's true of
any grandmaster worth their salt yeah
and so that's why wesley's taking his
time here
i like f3 i i didn't actually realize
that white can get the rook to d1 that's
sort of
the ideal scenario
yeah one rook barreling down the pawn
the other rook taking care of the open
file and the rook on b8 has a semi-open
line but that's why b3 was such a good
move because it's a protected pawn the
rook is just staring at nothing in
particular so i like f3 here and wesley
i think he had ben feingold over for
dinner yesterday so you know he's he's
not so sure that ben
ben might still be in the house
ben's in the background
don't worry everybody fair play checks
we know that the coast is clear there
but ben has made sure that wesley will
not be playing that move f3 or f6
anytime soon
yeah and he has sunk
three plus minutes on into this move
and now it's a blitz game
and knight a4 to c5 oh i don't know
about that
yeah what's the so i don't
understand at first why the bar went
down so much he takes away the d3 square
uh from any trades he did close the c
file you're right but he is attacking a6
now
you can't go r8 because knight b7 fork
oh gosh bishop c8 bishop c8 yeah i mean
he's vacating the g4 square for the
knight though i think that might be a
bonus a little
nice bonus of the move bishop c8 so rook
fd1 first just to uh force that queen
back to c7
uh
exactly
and that's not much more needs to be
said
oh
what
okay it goes back to a4
sometimes we ignite you for yeah
sometimes we praise top level players
for understanding they made a mistake
and retreating their piece back to where
it came from this was just odd
what and now rook fd1 no black does not
need to move a screen knight takes e3
and queen h6
what did what just happened
i mean h6 oh my god what's he's gonna
get himself checkmate what is he doing
okay so he's not made it because he's
the f1 square right oh jesus yeah now
dimitri look you could see him look at
his posture right before he was like
back and
oh
shenanigans a5 and bishop a6 oh my gosh
a5 is a sick move
bishop takes c7 black wins queen h2
check king f1 bishop a6 check
the king is brought out into the open
and executed by the queen oh my gosh
so dimitri is going to find this move
too
you just know it i'm just shocked that
wesley gave
not just free tempe right it's not just
like small little moves but and they
played a5 he gave his opponent
ideas the knight went to g4 the queen to
h6
oh my goodness oh my lance and lucas
look at dimitri he's giving him the
shush finger he's going full on dekambi
mutombo the finger wag is about to
happen get out of here can't believe it
i mean what is this turnaround
what is this turnaround wesley somehow
doesn't look phased but you could oh
there it is there's the head shake
finally you know his uh
his emotions are finally out there like
what did i do okay but but he needs to i
mean he's not losing and
he needs to keep himself composed calm
himself down and find the move queen e2
which actually might be the only move
and he just did yeah and he just did you
know queenie two is a move to close the
diagonal you often don't want to put
your queen in front of the face of the
king because you're thinking about a pin
but the rook's on b8 not on a that's a
very important distinction because there
is no bishop a6 and with the rook
staring each other down the d-file
maybe there's gonna be enough trades to
happen that the white king is going to
feel a little bit safer as the game
continues here two other important
details if black takes on c5 white's
knight recaptures in general and covers
the a6 square the second detail is that
if black
manages to engineer the move bishop a6
white can intercept it with a rook from
c4 so if you play rook a8 here then i
actually think white can take on e7
right and then cover bishop a6 with rook
c4 and potentially get two pieces for
the rook really important point there
and so if you think
don you just told me dish of a six was
the winning idea
things have changed here and i think
that now dimitri he is a tough decision
does he
keep the rooks on the board does he keep
the dark square bishops on the board
with a move like bishop g5
not easy for him so the eval bar it's
not misleading anybody but the position
is very complex
and dimitri's sinking
most of his remaining time
into this critical moment
this is
you know he couldn't have dreamed of
getting a queen to h6 and a knight on g4
like this
five moves ago and all of a sudden he
has this but how does he capitalize
he doesn't know i certainly don't know i
don't know
g5 maybe just like a neutral move yeah
that's what i was thinking he could also
play with like rook e8 but i'm a little
scared giving up the back rank so he
does play bishop g5 and i would just
swap quickly and play rook d1 and
now it's a fight once more it's easy to
forget that that rook is actually t8
yeah you make some other move but no
not wesley so and the bishop is going to
probably move back to g5
looks like a reasonable square to go to
and
okay so what's
what's his plan of infiltration is a
rook d6
type of move i don't know if it's
actually helpful knight b6 as well
is there
i'm starting to get worried about this
diagonal or the queen and the rook on e2
and d1 like if i can just somehow move
my knight and then get a bishop g4 but
it's too slow always
yeah it's hard to actually engineer that
so
for wesley and and he doesn't really
have any infiltration squares either the
bishop of course covering d8
black still has
um
the cards the idea of rook a bishop
basics that didn't go anywhere that's
still there it's funny it seems so slow
but it might be hard to stop and not to
mention there's a very common motif of
queen h2 and then bishop jumps knight to
h3 up you fortunately move your knight
out of the way after that but if that
bishop gets to h3 white is
dead
yeah white is tosto because bishop takes
h3 quinn h1 is mate so wesley
proactively moves his king away to f1
now importantly if knight h2 check and
bishop g4 then wesley can you know
despite ben feingold's presence
i think wesley will play f3 in that case
yeah
after
and one bar of connection by the way for
dima do you think king e1 is about to
happen here because if king g won knight
g4 we might just see a draw
but if the king goes
if the king goes to e1
i mean that's wesley saying i'm gonna
try to beat you because you are down
under a minute
yeah but then dimitri can still go back
to g4 and he will be threatening queen
h2 but no injury goes for the win okay
hopefully his internet he's back to four
bars here yep very good
and his threat this sounds funny because
knight f6 isn't threatening anything
directly but knight of six followed
bishop h3 is up to crush white's king
i mean it's what's called a second order
threat i mean they're a little bit
slower but they're just as serious
and wesley doesn't have anything to
latch on to on on the queen side and
knight b6 okay bishop b6 what now
and then knight f6 bishop h3 it's the
exact prince because rook d6 okay so
what's his plan after knight f6
that's the military
question so wesley always has moved f3
when bishop h3 is about to happen oh
because he's bishop g1 that's huge
that's huge
holy and then there's like bishop e3
anyway
oh gosh oh my god that's an incredible
pattern we might actually see that that
would be
crazy and that would just be winning for
black
but if wesley goes after here then he
drops the g3 pawn let alone knight h5
and the fact that h5 is totally
devastating
i mean holy spirit it says zeros but i
don't believe it i think wesley probably
has one move that survives and
everything else might just lose
exactly and he's down to 45 seconds
this has been a stunning turnaround he
played three oh no no no no h5 knight h5
sign the score sheets
knight f f6 to h5 chiseling at the g3
pawn devastating bishop f2 bishop h3
ends the game immediately
oh because that's beautiful because
you're after bishop takes bishop monitor
queen h1 check you don't even take the
bishop back because you want that knight
fork on g3 you might just see that or
wesley look at him he's pretty
distraught right now he had
the best position you could possibly ask
for oh here comes bishop h3 bishop h3
ends the game
and dimitri with 30 seconds to find it
and he doesn't need any of that time
oh you saw that a mile away
donny if you showed me that position
earlier and said out of 100 games how
many times does wesley so lose i would
say one and this just happens to be that
one it's demetri on dragon's day
incredible i cannot believe we just
witnessed that it's only moved 31.
10 moves ago
like you said i wouldn't have
possibly believed you that this position
would occur
in the same game and wesley lets his
time run out dimitri and draken with the
black pieces from a miserable position
somehow turns the tables in the span of
five moves and what does he do he takes
a drink from his mug you know that's a
science you know that's a sign of a
happy man and daniel i think we just
show bishop takes h3 we can point out
why wesley let his time elapse his queen
h1 check you don't even take the bishop
back because the bishop has to block and
knight g3 wins that queen with a fork so
i mean donna let's just go back in time
to the moment where wesley maneuvered
his knight and went back because
he let the game just escape him in in a
very odd way a very unwesly un-westly
sew-like fashion there will be plenty of
time for post-mortems but what i'll say
is what i think happened is wesley
played knight c5
and after bishop c8 he didn't fully
register the fact that the g4 square had
been vacated and he said ah let me go
back dimitri's probably going to defend
this pawn
but the moment knight 4 happens the
situation turns completely maybe wesley
overlooked the knight takes c3 attack
attacks the queen we won't know until
but whatever the reason is a very
uncharacteristic meltdown by wesley so
and all credit to demetria and draken he
is just a hawk
in terms of his ability to spot these
chances his talents were out he grabbed
the opportunity and he ran away with it
or flew away with it i should say but
either way once you beat wesley so you
should be happy but then you realize up
next is the matchup against hikaru
nakamura so the losers bracket final is
set it is hikaru nakamura it is dimitri
andreikin and we shall be right back
after this short break here at the rapid
chess championship finals presented by
coinbase
[Music]
so
use gifts from the biggest chess stars
on all of your favorite platforms
just search chess.com and your favorite
chess star on discord twitter whatsapp
and more to find hundreds of gifts from
chess.com's biggest broadcasts and
events hikaru magnus botez hess and even
me danny try it today
[Music]
coming up
is the women's fee chess championship
semi-final matchup between ho yifon and
valentina gunina the winner of this
match will take on katherine loch no in
the final you will not want to miss it
it's monday tomorrow 5 a.m pacific time
right here on chess.com
and while we're here in the rapid chess
championship presented by coinbase we do
want to thank hired they have been a
great
partner to have so
uh you know please hey software
engineers out there if you're tired of
getting random calls and texts with bad
job matches hired connects you to over
10 000 employers worldwide through one
easy dashboard no cover letters or
applications just upfront salary data
and dedicated candid experience managers
to support your incoming offers take
control of your career with hired
and we have a question for you it's
unhired what percentage of interview
requests in san diego were for remote
roles we asked you that question
yesterday i don't know if the new day
has given you any more insight into that
maybe you googled it so you kind of
cheated but our answer is don do you
know what it is
um
we're for remote rules well remote rolls
are
totally invoked am i allowed to guess
you can guess
okay i'm gonna guess 48
okay and i'm going to guess
i'll go with 53
so let's see what our answer is if our
producers can bring that up
come on
girl well
two-thirds of roles were for remote
opportunities or interview requests i
should say but wow thank you for that
information i guess the world is
getting more digital getting more remote
opportunities is a good thing allows
more people to apply for jawbird
speaking of san diego i remember when
there was a tournament
in san diego
and he wanted to play me remotely
from iceland but
remember he had the most interesting
shape remote control for his television
great
well we do have our two players set here
in the final of the losers bracket we
have demetri and draken many people were
predicting wesley soh to move on and get
a rematch against icaru but that was not
meant to be we have the first finisher
the top finisher the number one seed of
the rcc grand prix series that is zakar
nakamura he takes on the second finisher
that was dimitron draken and they're
down here in the losers bracket because
yon napomshi is a man on a mission he
refuses to lose he beat hikaru in
armageddon yesterday but akar he looks
fresh today don he looks ready to go
yeah and
it's not he didn't get crushed yesterday
it was a very very close match jan was
in incredible form
and i don't think hikaru is going to be
feeling
uh i don't think that that yesterday's
match in any way impacted hikaru's
confidence he has a good score against
sema in the rcc regular season but you
pointed this out yesterday dimitri has
beaten hikaru on more than one occasion
in the regular season and on draken he
has been an absolute buzz saw today and
yesterday and every day for his entire
life
and here we go
one could say he's feeling it and these
two they were supposed to square off in
the third leg of the feed of grand prix
series uh demetron draken had to
withdraw from that event so it was
unfortunate we couldn't see these two go
out of the classical chess but here we
go it's rapid chess it is a card
nakamura with the white pieces and it's
a vintage nakamura opening
yeah he's got knight f3 he's got the
queen side fianchetto
and we are very likely to see a pawn
appear on d4 sometime soon
but maybe not immediately the first
first thing is taken by hikaru but here
we go d4 and a quick trade by dimitri he
still seems to be within familiar waters
it's the type of position that
someone with that russian schooling like
dimitrov drake and he's like okay
isolated pawn i can do with that but so
many players hate having this pawn on d5
with no friend in an adjacent file
because it can be targeted as the game
continues but in return for an i say
pawn you get open files the e file the c
file let's see how dimitri handles this
yeah if anybody in the chat is
interested in sort of trends uh recently
i think the top engines are almost
always claim that that uh the side with
the isolated queen pond is fine even if
it is blockaded by
a knight that sits in front of it i mean
this is supposedly the ideal setup but
in this particular instance black's king
side activity is going to counterbalance
uh the weakness of the pawn and the
knight blockade case in point queen d6
is coming that's going to induce serious
and permanent weaknesses of white's
kingside yeah dimitri did not just
blunder opponent on c6 if you capture
twice on c6 you lose the game as white
because of queen d6 threatening
checkmate threading the bishop on c6 so
hikaru instead he just develops his
knight to d2
and oh look at the evil bar it's saying
black you were saying the top engines
they actually like this for the iqp side
and it's showing that after a simple
move like knight d2 which looks pretty
normal all of a sudden black maybe uh is
the size to be preferred
but apparently that was not
the correct
method
although
can you possibly blame dimitri
for playing the move queen d8 to d6
after bishop c7
i also don't really put too much stock
into the engines at this point because
they're gonna go up and down but there
are no game ending moves at the moment
so it's really about who has the better
plan so after g3 i'm sticking my bishop
on h3 you don't have to ask me twice to
start poking and prodding on those light
squares uh then the follow-up might
include rook c8 work f2e8 things like
that but it's still
a position without clearly defined plans
just yet and you don't have to ask
dimitri and draken twice he puts the
bishop on h3 you're absolutely right
position is somewhat amorphous you know
both sides have made
uh made the obvious moves now they have
to show
uh some sort of
consistent plan some sort of idea
black's idea probably will revolve
around exploiting the weak squares on
white's king side that's a lot easier
said than done
right and bishop f1 is trying to help
those light squares because when you
have a pawn on g3 there should be a
fiend kind of bishop around there the
bishop comes back home and danya one of
the big things is the tension between
the knights white doesn't really want to
take on c6 to fix black's pawn structure
if you will but then what is the plan
the knight blockades the isolated pawn
but also blockades your
access to the open d file
right
no i think bishop f1
is an excellent move
discharging the tension
tossing the ball right back into
demetrius court and watch out for knight
f5 if that light square bishop is ever
to leave the board the knight would have
accessed the f5 score which is why
dimitri says no no i mean i'll play
bishop g4 you can come back to h3 that's
not totally out of the question i think
it's just a good move
if i'm dimitri i'm not trading light
square bishops no no no no not 100 no
that's that's a major concession because
you mentioned knight f5
the bishop is the only device that can
actually fully exploit the light squares
right
and car is definitely not repeating no
but what does he do here maybe a3 just
to play b4 and get rid of this really
frustrating pin to that rook down on e1
so that comes to mind but i don't want
to take on c6 right i don't want to
allow bc6
maybe it's all right but it just feels
like it goes against the spirit of the
position
right
ooh
there's knight c6 bc6 and knight c4
though oh
well in that case maybe i do want to
play knight 66 because if black if you
can guarantee the black recaptures of
the queen but even that might not be the
most appetizing option
because the floodgates kind of i know
d494 becomes kind of a possibility
but maybe can we can we analyze this
very quickly because knight c6
pawn takes is that what you're saying
right knight c4 knight takes a5 and then
bishop takes f6 at the end
yeah no this is terrible no i meant
black has to take with the queen ah okay
okay and this i'm not sure how to
evaluate is what i'm saying got it okay
because i was like b you want to play b6
you definitely that's bc is just losing
so what is
you thinking
it's a bad sign
is he thinking of bishop takes d2
potentially but that also looks wrong
because after bishop takes d2
you can just take back with a queen on
e2 and now you've the bishop here as
white yeah don't tell me he's going to
blunder knight c4 there's no way no he
doesn't
and rook c when
okay where does the queen go now just
over to e6 probably
yep but then maybe the time is a ripe
for white to play a3 because if white
can go b4 stick the other knight on f3
you just start getting the sense that
black's initiative begins to unravel and
if it unravels then
positionally you know we know which side
has the upper hand it's white
right though now black can challenge for
the c file and the good news for on
draken is the queen is on d1 so these
rooks are not connected so you can swap
on c1 you can put your next work on c8
and maybe black is first to that fully
open line
the other interesting thing is that
after b4 bishop b6 white has to be very
careful about bishop takes e3 related
ideas
if white plays knight f3 then i can jump
into g4 you could even have a queen sack
on e3 so
white is not immune from
kingside shenanigans
not even a little bit in fact
just to move bishop b6 at any moment is
going to be scary for white to deal with
so rook f to e8 was played and
b4 you may want to get rid of the pin
but you're walking that bishop onto a
diagonal it probably wants to be on but
i don't know if there's an alternative
in he car it's mission critical for
white to be able to move this knight out
of d2 eventually
can you go back to his bishop f1 ideas
and
hopefully before again yeah i hope that
we can make a draw
let's dance bishop f1 bishop g4 bishop
e2
but am i wrong donya to start thinking
for hikaru that maybe not bail out
entirely but maybe i should
start being on my toes a bit because i
am looking at these bishop b6 knight
jumps from f6 into e4 or g4 and it does
worry me
yeah so in the line b4 bishop b6 knight
f3 i
i'm pretty sure that this is what hikaru
is investing his time in
you're absolutely right black plays 94
and knight takes f2 is a completely
devastating threat that just leads to
checkmate
even if white plays knight d4 black can
still play knight takes f2 because that
attacks white's queen
so i agree with you ricardo has to be
careful here he needs to tread very
cautiously because these tactics are not
to be trifled with and the plans are so
much easier to see from black's
perspective so
you know in return for having one weak
pawn on d5 that later in the game would
be a target for now it's clear that
black has the upper hand because the
tactics are in his favor
and with that in mind bishop f1 starts
making more and more sense
now after bishop f1
does black really have no dimitri will
go bishop g4 there's no need for black
to
seek any unnecessary adventures i mean
draw with black in the first game is a
great result for dimitri
should bishop f1 occur right i mean the
bishop on b2 is a fantastic piece so we
got to give credit to that one uh so if
you try to play on from blackside
unnaturally you may just be playing into
hikara's hand so i think that if we see
bishop one bishop g4 this kind of
repetition is likely and hikaru
i believe he's thinking about it no
chess player really wants to just make a
draw by repetition in a position like
this but if he's thinking about his
overall chances i think he's
in worse shape if he tries to do
something to play for a win he's just
look at the position be objective he's a
top player in the world he doesn't need
my advice but i do think that sometimes
we get into the mindset of i have the
white pieces let me play for more
and icaro is playing for more b4 is on
the board and he follows it up with
bishop e2 to f3 so what he wants is to
maneuver the knight through b3
and assign the bishop the task of
standing sentinel over
some of these key squares but we know
that that knight on f6 is going to land
on e4 and
right now there it goes
in three two
one then after 94 there's bishop d4 so i
kind of like what hikaru has done here
he
found a clever way of organizing his
pieces and the pawn on d5 remains
blockaded and if dmitry can't launch
like a serious attack
well then hikara will have the long-term
chances yeah and the interesting thing
is that hikaru is just in time because
the move 94 it actually threatens knight
takes f2 so bishop d4
is played in the nick of time
neutralizing
uh what is perhaps black's most
important piece the engine of the attack
but no hikaru goes knight d4 i wasn't
expecting that i was fully expecting
bishop d4
so where do we put the queen danya
can we put it on f6 i understand that
that oh
rook c2 instantly
okay defending the bishop setting up
the threat actually of knight c6
this is such a complex position right
now like knight g5 i really like knight
g5 because you freeze the knight on d4
and he's setting it up at some point but
the light squares are about to be very
vulnerable
yeah knight g5
is almost always dangerous in these
types of positions
with the queen also potentially making
contact with the rook that does not
that is not reassuring for white either
what a tense position bishop h5 by
hikaru forcing the queen
away again
chase queen of six bishop f3
queen of six is knight moves right
if if black goes queen h6 the queen
would have gone from e6 to f6 to g6
in succession and it was on d6 earlier
and c6 oh my god that's hilarious
i think queen g5 makes sense right
because queen of six runs into tactics
on the diagonal so queen g5
is what to me what
f4 what i never would have even
considered that move
what a committal
risky move by hikaru
oh my gosh
i don't know about that one demetrius
says hey thank you very much for the e4
square thank you for weakening your pawn
on e3 permanently
but this is what i was worried about
from hikara's perspective it's like he's
clearly playing for a win
but when you do so there's risk and he's
you know his king is looking a bit
breezy
but black's entire position is also
looking a little bit breezy like if okay
but knight f6
i was going to point out that g4
is on the table in certain positions but
definitely not here
queen d3
i feel like i just don't have a good
sense this position at all like i don't
either know where the pieces should go
where the why they're going where
they're going like what is exactly the
idea of the move
maybe a dragon should double on the e
file
it's like a
rookie seven
for lack of a better idea
makes a lot of sense actually
like what else are you gonna do
and i think of the rookie seven maybe
white should play for a4 a5
ah just to get rid of this
bishop and try try to make inroads on
the queen side because the king's eye is
not looking very good
uh so i would try to do something like
that
yeah you need to hurry up to
distract your opponent although actually
rookie 7 might walk into g4 in that last
position
okay but he played queen g6
i would say essentially forcing a queen
trade i i don't see hikaru refusing this
trade no
i actually think it's a very good
practical decision by dimitri
because now the e3 pawn is still tender
and you don't really have much to worry
about at the moment king f2 all right
maybe doubling
now looks equally as appealing and the
a4 idea is still very much on the table
and he plays it
and now i'm starting to get worried for
dimitri because yeah knight b3 bishop d4
these kind of moves will show why the
isolated pawn is not very strong and
icar can just operate right around it
yeah you just start getting the sense
that that queen trade dmitry may have
underestimated the queen side pressure
the impact of white's dominance
over the key d4 square
and so is a5 a serious threat that black
needs to deal with because then you push
your a pawn but you push your two
squares or one that's the big question
to me trying to figure out it is and
that has a clear downside as well if you
play a6
and white plays a5 and sort of buries
your bishop on a7 your bishop doesn't
really have any other prospects
but the bishop on c7 isn't all peaches
and cherries either
situation the time situation is getting
a little bit concerning for dimitri as
well we hadn't talked about that yet
wasn't a problem but he's down at three
minutes
and the complexity of the end game is
showing no signs of abating
it's very interesting because hikaru has
historically been seen as like great
tactician which he is but people
suddenly underestimate just how strong
he is in these queenless middle games
and games we saw him beat yon
napolishing at night end game yesterday
that was fantastic showing by him and
now here in this game where it looked
like if anything he might be with a
slight disadvantage he's suddenly
pressing and he's pressing on the clock
as well
dimitri decides to grab the bishop pair
ikaru
does not give him an opportunity to take
on d4 and get into an opposite bishop
position
no this is trouble for black this is big
big
trouble although after bishop f5 rook d2
can't black take over the c file now
rook c8 i think that's exactly what
dimitri has to do he has one chance to
do that
and that time is right now
although bishop b4 still will be the
response so it's not like
hicara has a tough choice there but then
the rook can get to c4
goes a6 instead
so he
has different priorities here now hikaru
cannot go rook c1 of course so maybe
this makes sense
you can keep
okay a5
oh this is starting to look back
starting to look really bad for andre
kidd car is just outplaying him it
really is as simple as that look at
white's pawns all on dark squares look
at black's bishop on f5 light square p
so if these dark square bishops get
traded dimitri is going to be struggling
to make a half point
yeah the bishop's going to have
absolutely no job i mean actually both
bishops are terrible here and now hikaru
has the opportunity to grab control of
the c file
if he wants to he can also play bishop
c5904 and keep chiseling his way into
black's position
maneuvering his pieces onto better and
better squares harassing black's pieces
and attacking the d5 pawn okay it's
definitely time for rook c in my opinion
give their great decision making by on
draken where
you give up your weak pawn and we talk
about this every single game you'd
rather be down upon with activity than
be just clinging on to that one little
piece there and suffering passively and
yonder pondish is one of the absolute
best players at demonstrating that
good decision-making there for on draken
and hikaru has made a ton of progress in
the last 10 moves or so
but
what exactly does he have to show for it
dimitri is still very very solid as long
as he can keep the d5 pawn safely
protected and he's doing a good job of
that so far yeah i think now simply f6
there he goes king f7 and if you're not
looking out for it that rook on c8 man
land on h8 and with a g5 pawn push for
black maybe there's some something to
look at
oh you can't take d5 cause bishop takes
d1 takes on b3 after that
that's
hawkeye tactical vision by dimitri
immediately dropping the bishop back to
f5 but now the rook on b2 for the time
being is kept at bay by this bishop it
can't move to c2
oh this is i mean the way demetrius
handled these last bunch of moves
what's the car's doing the shuffling now
i think dimitri can play g5 yeah rook h8
g5 things like that and
watch out because hikaru may
be better by the pawn structure but by
activity here comes dimitri on draken
well these bishops have been so
patiently lying dormant they haven't had
anything to do
they are itching at the opportunity to
emerge from their cages
and just
land in white's king's lap
and
not in a good way no no bishop e4 now is
possible because uh you can't attack
that bishop and if you take on g5 the f
file opens up not just the h file as a
potential avenue for black but the king
will go to g6 the rook will come to the
f7 square and then watch out for the
white king
but dimitri is taking a hefty amount of
time here he's deciding how to defend e5
he plays the most natural move bishop
before
and hicaro he's done a whole lot of
shuffling
and doesn't have a lot to show for it as
you're saying
yeah and the reason why the bishop
couldn't go back to g4 just there was
that uh the d7 work would hang with
check so the similar variations wouldn't
have worked out and then you'd also
would have lost the bishop on d1 right
so
king g1
okay
all right that makes sense to me or
protecting the h2 pawn
the problem for hikaru is there's no way
that he's making progress it's not easy
to find and swap on f4
maybe he doesn't need to make progress
because he keeps milking dimitri's clock
down no that's that's very true look at
dimitri go g5 the good thing about
double pawns is once you put one pawn on
the square you can also get the next one
there
and the more the position clarifies the
faster dimitri will have a chance to
play so he chooses the best moment to
play g5 now bishop d4 by hikaru paving
the way for the knight to take a turn on
c5 so rook c4
strikes me as
an interesting option here to go after
the queen side pawns
he goes rook e7 watch out for this f
file though i was just saying how black
could use the f file now the king went
to g1 rook f1 rook f6 and he plays it
yeah king jesus this is looking quite
scary to be honest king g8 maybe i think
you have to
i mean it's the safest square by far
if you go to e6 you might very well get
checkmated
he goes to g6 inviting rook f6 still
knight c5 instead which apparently was a
mistake for some reason
i don't know why bishop f5 rogue df2
forces the bishop away
wow i mean demetrius playing with fire
right now
is he trying to short team on this with
king
then he could get checkmated on f2 yeah
no that's that would be my concern and i
think i think dude you can play bishop
d6 just to try to get that knight out of
there oh my god he is trying to short
team on this
and will he carl infiltrate and if so
where f7 or f8
this is and who does the trade of rooks
favor well i mean you're not playing
knight takes e4 cause a rook takes e4
that sounds
bad for white so
what in the world
such a weird position it's hard for
either side to find a move here
i'm thinking work f7 yeah he plays that
so i like bishop d6 because you protect
your rook and try to get
opposite-colored bishops fantastic move
and you're aiming at b4 right immobile
taking the sting out of the move knight
takes b7
okay well now you can
i think bishop takes c5 and making the
media draw if you want it but maybe
dimitri wants more i don't know how he
gets more are you sure bishop takes c5
is an immediate draw after like bishop
takes c5 then d4
oh and you have plenty of activity for
that draw i agree
yeah i think you should do that he's got
29 seconds whoa bishop 65 is a big
threat
it's a huge threat it wins the game on
the spot hikaru might have to evacuate
the rook from f7 for that reason
oh my gosh demetria this guy when his
backs against the wall
he just plays better
to pin his own rook noticing that the
concrete idea bishop takes c5 justifies
it
nerves of steel the opposite you can
also play rook g7 if you want something
but still bishop takes five then b takes
d5 you're right that would be a draw but
the opposite end
of a pin is a discovery right and that's
what dimitri has shown uh promising
black would actually
have the upper hand there with the king
position he drops his bishop back on
onto a defended square
20 seconds for dimitri okay what's he
going to do g6 rook g7
oh he's got to calculate this he got 10
seconds he's got to move he's got to
make a move i think bishop g6 might be
the move and then bishop f5
okay just and then oh gosh he goes
bishop d6 he offers a trade because does
he want some kind of d4 at the end no he
doesn't there's a trade oh i didn't even
see that upon us hanging
wow
i think he simply wants to build a
fortress and on account of his piece
activity
i think he's fully justified to think
that this position is drawn
yeah his king is so active but kg2 and
h3 that's gonna happen bishop v5 king f5
back
kara knows how to squeeze these types of
positions out we've seen him do it so
many times i feel like well bishop c3 is
a threat so that's why it goes back and
now d4 can you just push this pawn
who's playing for a win here i'm not
sure
six seconds also white's pawns are oh my
god dimitri's hitting ducks move yeah
dimitri's bars of connection are going
down lagged he actually lagged yeah he
needs to stabilize that internet real
quick
like right
yesterday
he needs to have over 10 seconds
in case of
further lag
okay dimitri gotta go
oh he's lagging and oh his clock is on
four seconds i'm afraid he's gonna lose
on time
no okay he got it he got it off it's
just so nerve-wracking now king e3
blunders a bishop to bishop f4 check oh
my goodness you think it's like bishop
takes e5 how easy is that to make king
e4
and he plays g4 it should take c5 win no
oh great move by dimitri and that was
probably the only move
that was the only move bishop c6 check
and ikaro can try no h4 does it work
take it back f1 whoa king of six first
oh my gosh oh my goodness this is
i don't know i have no words for this
defense
and hikara down under 15 seconds himself
he takes h3 and bishop f1 and this is a
draw yes that's for sure because the
pawn on g4 is cemented on the light
square which also is on the c8 diagonal
and now you close your eyes you bring
the bishop back to d7 you anchor it to
the g4 pawn and white can no longer make
progress
dimitri scared us there
one last attempt by
by the way the a pawn the a8 square the
dark square bishop do not match just in
case something
you know
some bad things horrible yeah exactly no
this is over this is a draw and ticaro
offers one
and so does dimitri
whoo
what a slugfest
oh my gosh i mean that game it never
really hovered around it was like minus
around minus one at some point when the
queens were on the board then plus one
maximum for hikaru but that means
there's a very balanced game
i mean this was just
the players just put every ounce of
energy on the line in every critical
moment and when they got into the end
game i'll be honest with you robert i
thought icaru
you just got the sense that he started
out playing dimitri there was a stretch
where dimitri just found one
unbelievably masterful defensive move
after another yeah actually neutralizing
carl like that is is
i mean it's so impressive if we go just
quickly to that opposite color one
bishop takes c5 happened there a bishop
c6 shot was the only move and it seems
counterintuitive because you're giving
away your best pawn but as you're
pointing out king d5 is about to win the
game for white so he had to jettison
that pawn to win the h3 pawn and that
saved the day for dimitri andre again
and the fascinating thing is that if
hikaru goes king e5 the point of bishop
c6 check is to come around the other way
you take h3 take g4 and actually only
white can lose here because black is
gladly going to give up the bishop for
white's
c pawn so hicaro was forced to drop the
king back
and king f6 another incredibly cold
blood not rushing with bishop takes h3
the guy's got two seconds and he's not
taking the pawn
you know he takes it you know that's a
superstar player when you make moves
like that i mean just all the decision
making was pretty perfect from dimitro
and drake and hikaru because there's a
lot of praise for the way he put
pressure on dimitri from a position to
look better for black to suddenly not so
great but then f6 king of some g5 for
dimitri both sides really showed
fabulous chess the g5 was an amazing
move and that sense of when you go for
active counterplay and when you need to
stay passive that's a hidden talent that
uh that a lot of players don't realize
really stands behind some of the
greatest defenders in the world they
just know which levers to pull
and when to pull them
yes amazing amazing stuff so it seems
like the players are getting set for the
next game
dimitri he'll get the white pieces so
let's just talk about overall match
strategy car obviously just wants to
stabilize and neutralize whatever
opening edge dimitri gets we saw dimitri
against wesley
his opening with white was not
particularly impressive
no he played this sort of c3a4 line in
the grunfeld
and i think against ikaro dimitri is
going to play a little bit more
ambitiously i think he's aware that yana
pamyu should beat him basically with
preparation of catalan
i'm going to make the prediction that
dmitry pulls out all the stops and plays
something more mainstream we might see a
catalan we might see a queen's gamba
decline but
i think dimitri is going to
substantively change his strategy
versus his game against wesley
okay i think that's a good idea for him
i mean if i were in his corner i would
tell him the same thing because he just
sort of was dilly-dallying meandering
against wesley he got absolutely nothing
and wesley was on the verge of
outplaying him but dimitri as he just
showed in this game he showed the first
match as wesley he puts up sturdy
defense when he needs to but what he he
needs to avoid is time trouble against
ikaru because his connection hasn't been
great and hikaru is the best at
punishing you on the clock i don't know
if dimitri can survive another one of
these end games
with you know 10 seconds left
so he's gonna have to be efficient fast
a prep will have to be good
and going into an armageddon with icaru
is just not the best strategy for
success
no for sure not and
we know yon napom she he's waiting in
the wings he does not know who he's
gonna face yet will it be hikaru
nakamura the people's champion and we'll
be demetrion drake and the two-time
russian champion the superstar in his
own right that we keep saying this and
we will keep saying it he just somehow
is overlooked but here he is at minimum
a top three finisher in the rapid chess
championship he would like to make that
top two
what an
impressive result all around i mean
second place in the overall leaderboard
and uh second only behind hikaru
nakamura who he seeks to vanquish in
this second game
of their mini match we can take a look
at hikaru nakamura's hired player resume
at 34. he needs no introduction
introduction isn't even the right word
he doesn't we don't even need to talk
about him i mean
he is
among the most famous names in all of
chess he gets recognized on the street
icaru is a one-of-a-kind human yeah
bringing so many more fans into the game
of chess
he's been streaming but apparently the
stream went down that was part of the
issue and so trying to make sure that
everything is set
and
okay so we uh
are waiting for that so sorry to
everybody i know you want the games to
commence we do as well i think the one
person who's actually happy about this
delay demetrion draken he can sure take
a breath because that dude was on his
waning seconds against nakamura in that
last game now he can look at openings a
little bit and figure out do i want to
play a catalan against a car is there
something in a qgd a queen's game
declined that he likes i mean he can
sort of pick his poison at this point
and getting a little prep in with the
white pieces should be helpful
yeah you can attest to this as well when
you're actually playing the tournament
these breaks they might seem long if
you're watching or commentating but but
when you're playing you know it appears
that the game starts instantly i mean a
five minute break goes by in a
millisecond just because just catching
your breath takes that long
yeah it really does so dimitri he can
cool and sometimes he's also been
playing for longer than his car has in
terms of today's action because he had
to play a two-game match against wesley
which was nerve-wracking in that second
game he was in big trouble and he did in
fact win that to earn his way here
remind everybody of the brackets
look where he came from
yeah look at that the gauntlet from the
start he lost the first match against
episode
yeah and then look at the last slate of
opponents he had fabiano caruana
vladimir fetose who was lucky to even
have that half point because at the end
of that game there's a courtesy draw
offer he beats wesley so to make his way
through to hikara nakamura so
wow what a day it's been from him
indeed
it's been a tour de force
but now he has the ultimate boss
that he needs to vanquish shikara
nakamura the winner of this game is
going to go on to face jan nepamushi
in the grand finals okay here we go the
game is underway dimitri with the white
pieces and one knight f3 is his choice
all right so will he play c4 we get a
symmetrical english a la dingley ren
oh all right c4 and then we e6 so that's
very standard for a car he likes his
queen's gambit decline positions
he does an e3 again dimitri you know
going a little bit more conservative
here in the early going
and he's kind of doing to hikara what
the car just did to him right
oh well he went knight takes d5 and e4
so this
loses a tempo if you will compared to if
white had played knight c3 earlier but
it
limits black's options because there was
no knight takes c3 for black so these
little subtleties are really important
in the opening stage i think it's very
obvious
by dimitri's opening choice that he's
basically trying to play with no risk
now he's not trying to make a draw it's
very clear that he's not trying to make
a draw this end game is very combative
all of the pieces other than the queens
are still on the board essentially
but
he also wants to limit his losing
chances and he car offers a draw and
dimitri says
it no
that distinction you made is essential
because how many times have you played a
game daniel where you're like okay my
opponent just trading off pieces it
seems like they want to draw i'm just
going to make a draw in 10 moves and
then you're like oh wait my position
actually feels uncomfortable so i i know
i've had that plenty of times and
dimitri is the type of player and look
at this position by the way this looks
great for white like not anything why
would he take a draw here no not
anything where black is losing but why
can't i just play rook c1 take over the
c file moves like that and eventually
it seems like black is gonna be the one
lacking space no white is seriously
better i mean i think the ul bar might
be overstating things just a little bit
but i'd also point out that the b6 pawn
is a very serious long-term weakness the
big problem in these types of positions
is that if you push b5 the medicine is
almost worse than the cure and these
weaknesses on the a5 square and on the
c5 square that knight on d4 is perfectly
positioned to exploit them it can drop
back to b3 on demand
and uh you know do whatever on draken
needs that knight to do on the queen
side
and both players are going to keep their
kings in the center because after a move
like rook to d1 you have to watch out
your bishop is loose on d6 so king e7 is
played over here and well the h2 pawn
should not be captured don't go full
bobby fischer over there
in some variations maybe it can be taken
because you can't easily trap the bishop
with g3 there could be a knight h5 at
some point so just things to keep in
mind that h2 typically
not capturable here
there might be a moment where you're not
looking and it's scooped up
yeah i would go so far as to say that
this is something on draken has to
reckon with right now and precisely for
the reason you outlined if white goes g3
there's a weird knight h5 move and you
actually have a hard time defending the
g3 pawn
so a standard move for oh
i was just saying move forward
wow
although after bishop h2 there's also
the move f4 so it's not just g3 but f4
also locks the bishop in there but then
there's like knight c5 and then you play
bishop f3 but it gets incredibly sharp
and he carries the kind of guy who will
take on h2 if he thinks it works he's
not just going to say ah dimitri
probably saw something there he never
does that not icaru no he's gonna spend
quite a lot of time calculating that
right now because if he can take on h2
now he gets the upper hand because
dimitri has to prove that this was a
sacrifice not a blunder
i mean i
my guess is that dimitri just
quickly looked at this said i played g3
and stopped his calculation there knight
f6 to h5 is a very unconventional type
of resource and we know that even the
top of the top even these players they
on occasion are capable of missing a
resource like that
but this is the problem with playing
with your intuition rather than with
your calculation and picard does not
take buys it and i mean that's something
that maybe we could dive into a bit a
bit because that position uh was
fascinating with the possibility to take
on h2
and that possibility is still
there but now if you take on h2 i can
show this
really quickly after g3 knight h5
there's a key difference the knight on
d7 is now x-rayed by the rooks and
knight f5 check is absolutely
devastating
that's a key difference so if we look at
bishop h2 first instead of this uh rook
c8 move right so
is f4 the right player in g3 i think f4
is the right move
and just to show the point if black
takes on e4 hungrily at the end of the
day white plays rook h1 and traps the
bishop this way
still not the end of the game white
black has like e5 and stuff but
this
looks very dubious for black yeah maybe
there was something that was a little
more precise from white but the point is
that bishop gets trapped over there so
that understandably is what hikar wanted
to avoid because you're sort of walking
on eggshells throughout the rest of the
game where you're like uh oh i mean i
maybe i'm going to get out there maybe
it can't get trapped but you're just so
nervous and spending all of your energy
with that bishop so hikaru probably
believes in the stability the foundation
of this position but i believe that
white is just slightly better and so
this is exactly what dimitri wants and
that's exactly what i wanted to say i
don't think hikaru feels desperate
enough to take on h2 i think he's very
confident that he'll be able to make a
draw here and he's confident in his
armageddon chances so
we can see from the opening that he
chose and the way he's playing this game
that he's determined
to sign the peace accords and to get
into an armageddon and he's not going to
do anything drastic unless he is very
confident that
uh it's going to work out well something
drastic that i'm wondering about is
bishop takes c3 following a bishop takes
e4 in actual option
for black because you're getting
two pawns and a rook for two minor
pieces but with the king on e7 in the
center i feel like the minor pieces are
going to shine for white and that's
exactly why dimitri makes this g4 move
because you're trying to remove the
guard of the knight on d7 and you showed
some excellent tactics regarding this
hanging piece on d7 and so if you try
some kind of bishop takes c3 bishop
takes e4 stuff now i guess the point is
that white just has g5 and says you're
not even getting your
rook for those minor pieces i'm just
winning the minor piece such a cool idea
and this is almost indirect prophylaxis
so many players if they would have
gotten scared of bishop c3 bishop before
they would have made a move like bishop
d3 or move their king away but top
players they know how to weave
prophylaxis naturally into
uh the way that they play so that they
don't disrupt the coordination of their
pieces in any way now g4 it's a pretty
committal move from a positional
standpoint
but it's also really annoying i mean g5
is an all-out threat right now
yes so h6 would be my first instinct
that's how i'm gonna deal with this pawn
push and i don't think black should be
afraid of white fully sending with h4
and g5 but instead of carving springs as
rook to d saying i have everything
defended now so i know g5 yeah the g5
will kick my knight back to a square
like e8 but that's not the end of the
world and i can keep maneuvering my
pieces
yeah and eventually white might bite off
more than he can chew if white keeps
pushing these king side pawns up the
board in some later end game and a
couple pieces come off the board white
might regret that but hikaru he sneaks
the knight on h5
is definitely surprising i don't love
that because as white here
one thing to note is the c3 almost
called the c3 pawn in the event of
bishop c3 ponzig's rook takes c3 there
are many positions where that leaves the
rook on d8 and the knight on d7 in
trouble so like for example if i play
knight b3 here or knight c2 it'll be
actually even more forcing 902 is better
oh i like your knight c2 move okay and
then take on c3 you can't easily take
twice in this position i feel like
because of bishop b6 tactics maybe not
right away because c2 is also hanging
but the point is that you're hanging by
a thread here is black right and there's
ideas of f4 bishop d4 bishop f6 i mean
oh god mike's got an abundance of
different ideas here but and and draken
plays your move he plays knight b3 and i
think the reason why is he wants to
discourage uh the move bishop b4 to c5
so this makes
this makes a lot of sense to me as well
and he wants the knight to be poised to
exploit the a5 square right and
that was five and it's not on h5 it's
just offside over here and it is looking
particularly dim so
knights on the rim are kind of you know
they're it's unfair how much they're
bullied but i'm not enjoying the night
on h5 in this game dimitri could not ask
for a better end game here he's up on
time he's got a better position he's not
risking at all he's basically playing
for two results as of this moment yeah
and he's got icaru in a very
uncomfortable spot
and he wants that move b5 to be played
because as soon as b5 is played i look
at that a5 square and i play move a3
just you take my knight on c3 you win
that pawn have fun with it because i am
going to infiltrate on the dark squares
and your the pressure on the d file will
be
probably too much to bear so i i think
hikaru needs to find
an only plan that's an only move here
but he needs to find a plan so he
doesn't just get pushed back and kind of
crushed
yeah the bishop on before also doesn't
have any real estate along this diagonal
so one idea would be to drop the king
back yeah
solves the problem radically he just
gives the bishop up
bar not a fan of that
yeah i can understand why i mean look at
this knight f4
right
but can white go rook d6 here
looks very interesting
also or is there something
bishop f1
okay if knight f4 can i take on f4 and
take on d7 and then bishop h3 check at
the end how does that work
so you take here i was thinking about it
bishop h3 i think just bishop hd first i
mean you've got black
oh yeah you're pinned forever
or or
god it's plus five here what's the move
is it knight d4 first trying to go to f5
oh it's just 94.
and is it knight
e2 and knight takes f4 i think this
might be the idea just going after this
pawn that's plus five
apparently that's plus six almost oh my
gosh how could you not realize that
bishop h3 and the 92
but this is shame on me
no i actually f1 is findable though no
bishop f1 i was just trying to go to
this endgame thinking that a knight
against bishop could lead me to a
promising end game especially with your
pawn on f4 as a target uh but i might i
mis-evaluated that i didn't definitely
not see a plus six variation with uh
just a simple knight d4 move bishop f1
is such a dangerous move this maneuver
is oh
this is turning and he plays it wow
uh-oh
and hikaru has to he's walking on hot
coals right now
knight f4 really plus six amazing
it's crazy how that just happens like
you just
you know these positions are if you
think okay plus one plus two maybe
no plus six
no i mean and not just totally paralyzed
that's the point but no player thinks
like that right no players like oh this
is this winning for that no i've got
great winning chances but it's just
shocking when i hear numbers like that
in a position that looks just better for
white but not completely and utterly
winning uh so what does cicara do
yeah that's just about to ask you right
because bishop h3
is like a winning threat
yeah black will be up tied in complete
knots and probably also losing a ton of
material i mean b6 is gonna fall at some
point
it's always the problem that pushing b5
is
totally out of the question makes way
too many weaknesses on the queen side
i don't see a move you ask me what is
black dude i really am not
finding a movie so that
i guess we might have to go back to that
ending where does black actually have
chances being down upon there
it's
objectively terrible
but maybe there's some practical chances
yeah i guess you
and he was bishop h3 so
knight d4 not seen he rushed it a little
bit and bishop c6 is excellent now if he
plays knight d4 the bishop has this a4
hiding spot
and i think the situation becomes a
little bit more complicated
wow but bishop actually was such a
natural move yeah no you cannot blame
dimitri for playing bishop
but if he took a little bit longer he
might have spotted bishop c6 and then
that would have given him a chance to
see knight d4
it's true i think white would have just
tied black up all together and knots as
you
like to say so here bishop a4
where is the rook going to is he going
to take d7 yes bishop takes d7 i think
he wins a pawn for white right oh a 92
and he finds that as well
yeah if rook 67 there was knight f5
check
this is really really really bad for
hikar because here's the thing robert
he's gonna have to move his bishop and
that dovetails in with your point
earlier they're gonna get a knight
versus bishop end game where dimitri has
a four on three on the king side this
should be completely winning no the
knight vs bishop ending that i was
confident was winning that's what i was
aiming for to begin with
so hicaru quickly took on d7 with the
bishop and that was maybe a
game-changing mistake it seemed that
rook takes d7 still gave chance but that
looked bad after a knight f5 check so i
can't really blame mikaro too much for
quickly taking with the bishop even if
it is objectively losing and he drops
the king back to ea trying to make it as
difficult as possible for dimitri to win
this pawn with the king on e7 knight
takes f4 was an immediate threat because
you could not take on c3 due to
the fork on d5 now you can
yeah but knight f4 looks okay so
dimitri's rook d6 which is good but if
knight f4 rook sees knight h5 going the
other direction
winning material
great catch as well but i like dimitri's
move he keeps the status quo
he's just stepping on hikaru's toes here
well this is i think the best move by
dimitri and the reason why is c3 is
defended b6 is under attack and if you
move the bishop we just transpose to
exactly what we were looking at a moment
ago a winning minor piece ending for
white so we have a minute delay from
hikaru's stream video to you know what
where we're at but what we're not
delayed about is this lead on the clock
for andre he's double hikara's time in
addition to having a winning position
yeah
here we go this again
now
i have nothing to say there are no moves
i mean look at the defile pressure the
f4 pawn is about to fall
ikaru might have nothing better than
going into this knight versus bishop n
game and what exacerbates the problem
in that endgame is that white's two
queenside pawns will both be on dark
squares they can't even be attacked i
was gonna say i think b5 might be the
best practical chance
and dimitri doing the smart thing he's
not just taking on a6 he brought his
rook up to take some pawns over there
but that may give black the opportunity
to get some counter play where you might
be down one pawn maybe two but if you
have some things to counter with then
you're feeling better we you know we've
said countless times at this point that
you much prefer to be down material with
some play and if you just play knight
takes that f4 rook takes you through
knight h5 donna that looks just over
no you're i agree completely but dimitri
doesn't hurry he just plays h4 this was
russian school of chess move ever yes
he's making all these little
improvements g5 now defended just in
case and he's probably gonna play a3 too
that would be very consistent with the
strategy gosh
but eventually he's going to have to
press some sort of a button
right have like a3 rook d1 to d2
move the king somewhere
and then do one of d3 but if he doesn't
play a3 then he carve plays b4 and fixes
the pawn on a light square i think it's
actually quite important for dimitri to
go a3 here or to take on f4 and go
knight h5 one or the other
of course rook d2 right and he do this
for a reason
because if b4 is played he'll take on
before and then take on f4 and now
there's no rook takes c3 so he was
worried about rook takes two three he
might not be focusing on knight h5 it is
a bit obscure we just saw how bad
black's knight was on h5 but now the
white knight would be an aggressor
rather than just an offside piece i
think he's basically intent on forcing
this into the minor piece end game and
he's going to try to engineer the
situation
a3 might have been a mistake though
hikaru has saved these positions in the
past well what can black do like what if
he just keeps
taking f4 eventually and just go knight
h5
yeah so what do you do in this position
rook d3
i
if your car saves this i mean no i mean
this is
i have a feeling he's gonna draw this
he's down two minutes on the clock and
he can't move any of his pieces
oh wait a second though but black's
about to go rook d8 to c8
yeah but then the bishop will hang if
you take on c3 you know but then you
move the bishop you get to keep the
pieces on the board right
oh okay which is why dimitri
he kind of stalled a little bit too long
and hikaru was starting to unwind his
tentacles
just a little bit
and that's the thing right some players
they
are a little bit too methodical and he
was h5 which whoa
oh he's trying to shove the pawn down at
h6 to carve out this massive hole on f6
okay that actually
that's good technique and if rook c8 now
or d8 to see that is he'll take on f4
because the rook can't take on c3 d7 is
hanging and he does and hikaru drops the
rook away to b7 h6
h6 is the move
that's definitely the move it just wins
[Laughter]
oh gosh this again dimitri
doesn't play age
six every ounce of counter play yeah i
have to say like it's sort of amusing
but not because i'm laughing anyone but
because i know how miserable it feels to
play these type of positions against
someone like i'm draking right there are
boa constrictors breathe
it's like every single move is with
purpose
and you have no counter play whatsoever
okay h6 time
it feels know
what the end result of the game is going
to be you know where this is all going
but yeah h6 is a total no-brainer he's
got to play it
i mean that's why he played h5
presumably to play h6 i i assumed so but
now he's not moving there it goes there
he goes g6 and he just needs one or two
more accurate moves what are they knight
d5 check not accurate because you
blunder your rook on d6 so move that
rook out of the way
where do you put it rook off six maybe
not six you want that square belonging
to the knight right maybe rook a6
another idea is to go rook d5 and rook
e5 a little bit obscure but
potentially a good way to apportion the
squares
that looks pretty clever actually is
down at two minutes that is ikaru's only
hope only hope that dimitri gets low on
time and gets nervous it's amazing that
we say that when hikar himself is down
under a minute but that's how good
hikaru is he's the bullet chess champion
he has won crazier positions than this
bishop c six i would check and then go
to c5 i'm not sure yes i like that
because there's some background checks
that black needs to be careful about now
and now
the andrinking way to play this would be
to play like king e3 right he goes rook
d6 infiltrating
further
oh my gosh after bishop b7 he's probably
like rook d8 check oh
oh my goodness
if no rook f6 now that's
why he carved that square out
okay so is he gonna
oh do you take him over if rook thinks
b5 you can't take c3 without losing f7
yeah that's another pawn and he takes it
this is
90 96
check is unnecessary because of king e7
wow he just
he has prevented hikaru from doing
anything
he's eating him alive
okay what's the finishing blow is it 92
just dropping the knife back keeping the
pawn alive
maybe night okay night oh my god 92 why
give up a c3 why give him any counter
play
this is that bishop this has been a
master class
can you just and hikaru he won't die we
know he just every move he'll keep it as
difficult as possible oh my gosh the
reason for before now another amazing
idea gosh the guy just he he's such
great full board awareness
like he has done a tremendous job of
giving hikaru zero counter play
yeah he's taken him completely out of
commission and king e3 is going to come
at some moment i can feel it
like right now like right now
or rook b4 i don't see a problem with
that
no
look before there is no problem with the
rook before rook before actually ends
the game
and he plays it
oh goodness is this resign time
you know how they say a picture is worth
a thousand words this
demonstration of chess excellence is
worth all the words i've ever said in
commentary
yeah i'm speechless
you're absolutely right it was
even continues
just like the way the filigree precision
with which he just deprived cicara have
even a chance to attack a pawn
right rook before
rook d5 let's offer a trade we're up
three pawns right now
but he's down under a minute
and king g3 continues to improve his
position hammer away at hikaru's pieces
oh my gosh i'm pinning the bishop on
knight d4 is probably
winning but he might not even want to
give up the c3 pawn so he'll play some
other move
like a check on d4 and knight f4 yeah
centralization is important
beautiful knight f4
my gosh
rookie check now will not go away
no but you gotta tip your hat damn it's
54 moves in
is he gonna go he goes ninety two four
oh good guy the guy is insane he just
doesn't give him even a single chance to
take a piece a four
oh my gosh
or rook h8 yeah rook eight shade is two
oh no we're getting too active
rookie
don't drop your g5 oh yeah that would be
the best way to complicate the game yes
he just goes like this he's up three
pawns in a rook end game anything wins
king b6 rook b8 he's got plenty of time
and b6 nope rook h8
look at this look at this
just an unbelievable display of
technique from dimitria and draken ikaro
is going to be upset but
we all have to tip our head this was
would it be an exaggeration to say that
this is one of the greatest positional
rapid games we've ever seen
it was
pure class from dimitri on drake and the
game technically is not over but when
you're four pawns in a rook end game it
doesn't matter if you're playing
don't go king e5 and blunder f6 oh that
would be tragic and you might still be
winning yeah but he still gets
completely winning actually
look at c4 make sure the f3 pawn is safe
and sound h8 h7 h7
and the death
bell starts to
sound ca check i'm sure he'll go
king d4 hikara with one last attempt to
get blacks and whites king to mating net
but there's nothing b6
oh
what oh
trying he's trying
is there a meeting there like if he just
plays b7 just play
king g3
oh my gosh he's just toying with him at
this point oh rook a7
that's it
dimitri andre look at him did you see
that and now he has to play
right but he just took down
wesley so and hikaru nakamura back to
back in completely different ways he
beat wesley in a tactical melee he takes
down hikaru nakamura in one of the
finest positional displays you will ever
see in a game of chess and now his
reward
is a showdown with yonda palmashi
that was
such a treat we were watching a master
at work he gave ficaro's zero zero
counter plan once he got that small end
game advantage he chiseled and
maneuvered
and maneuvered and maneuvered and kept
squeezing it out until hikaru just had
no life left among his ranks
that was simply breathtaking
no matter who
who you're rooting for that was amazing
even in that last can we just go back to
when hikar went f6 just you know two
moves ago
right or whatever that was like the
point frank caro is he wants like a rook
g1 rook f7 and a checkmate on that king
on f4 some kind of weird configuration
it's like a self-made but dimitri was
king g3 so he doesn't have to worry
about his king safety every single move
by demetrion drinking had purpose and i
mean that's really the only way you can
knock out hikaru nakamura i just want to
point out knight f4 to e2 the retreating
night move going to d4 and b5 defending
c3 he didn't give away a single one of
his extra pawns and it wasn't just
because he was being aimlessly greedy he
was being ridiculously precise and
hikaru nakamura offered a draw to
demetrion draken early on this game as
you called you're the prophet for a
reason demetri isn't playing a queenless
position to make a draw he's playing it
so he doesn't have to risk any tactical
opportunities from ikaro's perspective
and what a game that was so that sets us
up for the grand finals we know who our
remaining two competitors are it is yon
napomshi who has gone unblemished
throughout the rapid chess championship
finals and now we know he takes on
dimitria and draken who made it through
the losers bracket donya
what a treat
the rcc has been a treat all 25 week
regular season long these four day
finals have flown by and i cannot wait
for these grand finals my seat belt is
fast
it is tightly fastened and i suggest
that you do the same if you know what's
good for you well i'm gonna stretch my
legs because i know we're in for so much
more exciting chest this is the rapid
chess championship finals presented by
coinbase we'll be right back for the
grand final between donna palmschie and
dimitri andrei
[Music]
mmm
it
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
and here we are back at the rapid chest
championship finals presented by
coinbase we are ready for the grand
finals now demetrion draken he gets a
well-deserved breakdown yeah he gets a
few minutes to uh recuperate from two
very difficult matches
i don't know that's kind of really
asking a lot very demanding you know
he wants a five-minute break after he
defeats wesley and picaro in two
successive masterpieces and
yeah i don't know why we gave it to him
what a guy but the format is grueling it
is demanding because he needs to win two
matches in a row as he takes on yonder
palm tree because gianna pompsie he is
the
winner's bracket
victor and we just found out on draken
is his challenger and they will play
typical matches two games white and
black in the ten minute plus two second
increment the difference being that
janna pomshi needs just one victory and
drake needs to do it twice
and obviously all the cliches apply
andreika needs to go one match at a time
he needs to almost tell himself that he
needs to win one match and then when he
wins the first one
you just need to do the same thing again
pretty easy just beat jan twice like i
said at the start how easy can it how
much easier can it get oh yeah i know
that sounds like the biggest challenge
you could give someone right now yonder
palm she is a man on fire winning the
candidates just going through the
gauntlet here at the rapid chess
championship but he has a tough match in
store against demetrion draken so while
the players they get set we are very
happy to share with you these great
video from
chess the history of chess a reflection
of us stay tuned we'll be back for more
from the rcc but enjoy this video in the
meantime dating back to 6th century
india
chaturanga is the earliest known form of
chess and bores similarities to today's
game
variations of the game spread to the
sassanid empire or modern day iran where
they were taught to nobility
after hundreds of years these early
versions
slowly converged into the modern game we
enjoyed today
chess traveled east to china where it
evolved into a game called xi'anji
the game also traveled west as islam
swept through arabia north africa and
the iberian peninsula
by the middle ages chess was being
played throughout europe
the game reached mongolia through silk
road routes and genghis khan spread
chess throughout the empire in the 1200s
as the european renaissance ushered in
an era of rebirth chess became popular
with the artists scientists and
religious leaders who dominated
renaissance culture
in fact
it was a catholic priest
rui lopez de segura who in 1561
published one of the earliest and most
influential books on the game which
documented the priest's opening theories
including his namesake the rui lopez
which is still a common opening nearly
500 years later
the 18th century ushered in an era of
revolutions most notably on the american
continent in france
and even in global industry
napoleon bonaparte was known to play
chess with his generals
benjamin franklin a founding father of
the united states was an avid chess
player who penned the essay
the morals of chess in 1786 where he
wrote life is a kind of chess
in which we have often points to game
and competitors or adversaries to
contend with
[Music]
today chess.com is excited to release
the history of chess a reflection of us
chess.com's documentary tells the full
story of chess from its origin in india
to its diffusion throughout the world
and into the modern era learn about the
champions who have defined the game such
as paul morphy bobby fischer gary
kasparov and magnus carlson from some of
the game's greatest players and
commentators including vishwanathan
anand bruce pandelfini ben feingold and
danny wrench watch the premiere today
immediately after the show at
go.chest.com
history of chess again that will be
available after today's show here in the
rapid chess championship because all
eyes should be on these two players
dimitri andreikin yon napomishi and you
see the l next to one drinking's name
here done and not because that's what we
expect from him but that's where he came
from
came from the losers back and not just
from the losers bracket from the very
beginning of that bracket what an
incredible journey he had and if we take
one more look at our bracket to refresh
our memory here over way on the bottom
left eons and millennia ago
one
day
in the 16th century and dragon had to
defeat fabiano carawana
in the first
part of the losers bracket he went all
the way defeating carawana vladimir
putin wesley and hikaru nakamura and now
has to defeat john de pomneishi two
times in a row and that doesn't even
include his earlier wins over jeffrey
zhang and the losers
the guy went through everybody possible
because as you pointed out against
nordivec abdusitara of an
uncharacteristic double blunder he
blundered minor pieces in both games and
then as you see on the screen in front
of you he beat poravian he beat zhong he
beat karwana he beat fedo say so and
nakamura can we just like anoint this
guy the world champion at that point you
know that that's ridiculous no this is
one of the greatest uh
online chess runs ever ever i mean
nobody's managed to do that
and this we're not talking about a
bullet tournament here we're not talking
about you know three plus zero or title
tuesday we're talking about serious ten
plus two mini matches in which he's
beating these people
incredible i mean the way he's played
has just been a sight to behold and now
he is hey playing game one with the
white pieces against yonder palm she
goes for knight f3 against the fresh
bomb issue a very
who has not lost the match to this point
that's right and yada pamyashi who won
the candidates tournament and is
supremely confident so dimitri he's got
the white pieces in game one here he
repeats the same opening from game two
against ikaro he has to keep his foot on
the gas pedal he can't give the white
game away because jan has been
completely unstoppable with the white
pieces and jan's preparation has been
spectacular and that's an understatement
the way that yon beat hikaru nakamura in
that bounce back game two with that deep
catalan preparation with the exchange
sacrifice for a couple pawns that was
something and right now dimitri is doing
the most dimitri thing ever you're just
saying let's play in a position that i
feel comfortable in not tactical at all
let me outplay you in just this
casual game but it could get tactical
because white's typical idea in such
positions is to play b2b4 fian ghetto
the bishop on b2 and white's pieces come
into the center very very quickly so
what you will sometimes see
is
once the knight moves away from c3 if
white can get the bishop to b2 in a
timely fashion threats could be made
against black's king
that's that is true for sure and what
i'm noticing in addition to the plans
you mentioned is that yana pomshi he's
spending quite a deal of time at this
point he doesn't want to choose the
wrong plan because in this position does
this plan bring the knight to d7 as he
just played or knight to c6 those are
important questions that you can't
answer later you need to figure it out
right now
and of course this all leads into the
big question of
how to develop the light spread bishop
my guess is that jan will play b6 and
bishop b7 he wants to do the same thing
dimitri wants to do so we might see both
sides
developing their minor pieces in a very
very similar manner and later on down
the line jan could try to stick a rook
on c8 and really challenge all of
dimitri's pieces on the c file
and as you're pointing out that bishop
is going to be fianchettoed sometimes
you play a6b5 other times you just
settle for b6 these little things
yeah these little things they're really
consequential
now yeah such as where you develop your
pieces yeah it doesn't really matter not
against someone like dimitri andre he's
not going to punish you for wrong
development no no no he doesn't care
he's just happy to be here and he gets
minimum twenty thousand dollars second
place in this event 20k
and it's very deserved for whoever ends
up in second but right now yondu
palmashi with the black pieces he also
just has the benefit of he can lose the
first match he'll get that rematch
dimitro draken does not have that same
right
but there will be huge momentum on
dimitri's side if he can win the first
match so jan from his perspective he
wants to end it right here and right now
he definitely does and i think that
dimitri has many new fans i don't think
after this we're going to say oh people
overlook dimitri now he's getting not
anymore the credit and the respect that
he deserves but right now his position
he plays e4
which is a big move because with the
queen on c2 you were indicating this
before dynamite look at the h7 pawn
maybe there's an e5 a knight g5 and
white's pieces spring to life
dima is going after him and that
explains yan's move queen c7 preventing
e5
and of course aiming at the h2 pawn but
this is more of a defensive move than an
aggressive move it also poses the
potential threat of bishop takes f2
check
that's right so knight b5 kind of takes
care of multiple issues at once you
attack the black queen and it's not just
to attack the queen it stops your bishop
f2 check because the queen now protects
the bishop on c4 and then i'm gonna
follow with pawn to b4 bishop to b2 and
i feel like white is gaining important
space
from an aesthetic visual visual
perspective i agree completely i think
white's position looks more pleasant
what could be
the other candidate move here other than
knight p5
do you see anything that catches your
eye
no no
neither does dimitri yeah no i was i
wanted to play b4 and i couldn't do that
without dropping f2 in a moment ago so
now b4
is a very nice move
yeah i cannot imagine on draken playing
anything else e5 clearly doesn't work
uh one
important detail e5 knight takes e5
bishop f4 never works in such positions
because knight takes f3 is always check
that's good to point out so what is
dimitri thinking about because
isn't the whole purpose of this opening
to play the move b4 why they hired the
commentators that they did for this
tournament
[Music]
that would be a reasonable thought
well maybe he's thinking
no rook d1 weakens the f2 pawn and it
doesn't really pose any obvious threats
okay and then black will happily play a6
bishop b7 and so on
no i was thinking maybe he wants some
bishop g5 bishop h4 bishop g3 but it's
way too slow
and he just burned like a solid 90
seconds on these last two moves yeah
it's very strange because you know you
played knight b5 b4 was
the follow-up and he could have made but
not 95 but he could have been before
instantly and instead he has
given himself a two-minute hole two and
a half minute hole at this point right
and i would argue that bishop b2 is
another very natural move that i would
be playing pretty quickly
maybe he's gonna go for your bishop g5
bishop h4 bishop g3 maneuver and that's
been made more appealing right by the
fact that there is a black bishop on e7
because at some point later down the
line e5 could become a semi-dangerous
idea as well
that's right so i'm a little concerned
about dimitri's clock management thus
far and i wonder if fatigue could be
setting in because it even though it's
been what two hours of chess just the
stress of playing wesley so and akara
nakamura i mean that adds up and so
dimitri you know he's a great player
he's played uh blitz matches for hours
and hours and hours but you have to
recognize he's human after all he
definitely is and
right now he's facing an unbelievably
confident yan who is once again playing
with unbelievable confidence he's only
spent a minute
and do you get the feeling that yon's
pieces just breathe they just they just
flow it's like watching steph curry when
he's on every piece
is of course i had to nerd out with a
basketball analogy it's all good but you
know what i mean every piece is on
a perfect square there's just a certain
oomph to his play that makes it so fun
to watch and i think we both agree it's
not just this game it's just the new yon
apanshi over the last few years and it's
weird to say that somebody who's number
three in the world by raiding and it
might be underrated but i think the way
he's been playing the maturity he shows
and just the
cohesiveness of his plans and
clock management i think that yeah he is
really just a menace on the chessboard
right now and dimitro and draken he just
brought bishop back to d3 i think he's
telegraphing what his intentions are e5
but black could just play rook c8 and
does just that are you really going to
play queen b1 no it's queen e2 so i
don't know i don't feel like
dimitri is as harmonious of a plan right
now
well i remember my coach teaching me
that e4 in such positions tends to be an
incredibly risky move because you weaken
the entire complex of dark squares
around the center and you also limit the
prospects for your bit there we go case
in point knight h5 aiming for f4 but
what is jan's follow-up going to be here
he's induced g3
but
uh was that a little bit of the old
yonder robert yeah we were just talking
about how harmonious and cohesive his
pieces were that move is a night on the
rim that isn't looking very good and i
think that white can play e5 soon which
might strand that iron h5 and you'd be
very careful that you're not walking
into a vicious attack i know e5 does not
look promising just based on the fact
there's a bishop on b7 slicing across
the position but when a knight is
trapped on h5 it can be worth going for
i think that's a prudent decision by jan
to go back but he has just invested two
tempe
in inducing a move that arguably isn't
even harmful i'm not sure the g3 creates
any further appreciable weaknesses in
white's position this gives dimitri a
golden tempo that he can use to bring a
rook into the game rook ad1 rook fe1 and
in the grand scheme of things that's a
pretty big deal
and i know today's not thursday but i
hope that demetrius is enjoying himself
a little throwback because if we just go
back two games or two matches ago
against wesley so remember what wesley
did he went knight c5 knight a4
and jan just went knight h5 knight f6
and it gave dimitri the time he needs to
launch an attack i mean knight g5 pawn
e5 these kind of ideas might really be
harmful for black's king
i like that move though a7 a5 chipping
nibbling away at the edges trying to
carve out the c5 square for his knight
and i think that jan's primary strategy
should be
to launch a direct attack against this
e4 pawn if that is possible
this poses dimitri with a difficult
challenge how is he going to defend the
b4 pawn
is he going to defend it at all
i feel like there are some
lines like this so bear with me
for a second knight g5 okay if you play
h6 come play knight takes f7
you know like these type of sacrifices
where you then
i know is it equal let's say zeros
of course
of course according to our the theory
that we developed yesterday
such positions are always the same
evaluation yeah like it's super unclear
the king is not safe but it's just zeros
and there's even this bishop page to
stop thinking from escaping i won't
pretend like i saw bishop h7 as a
concept
okay this is what's happening oh my god
you called it
you called it knight g5 is on the board
i can't believe it but you know exactly
what i'm talking about right those
lines and like the bot vinegar sometimes
so yeah exactly that's what i was
thinking about to paulo
to paulo against kromnic had a very
famous game where he just sacked on f7
ran seemingly at random in the opening
and didn't even seem to have a clear
follow-up and yet the permanent weakness
of the king
is often the sole motivation for these
types of sacrifices
and they're unbelievably difficult to
face practically i love the move knight
g5 can black respond with knight e5 do
you have to play h6
are you
i
cast 95 but i'm wondering if i can just
like show back an f4 and maybe you're
inviting too many of my pieces into the
attack
that would be my main concern
yeah actually more ideas 95 major bishop
e5 and followed by f4
oh and then quickly you just steamrolled
me with e5 yeah you need you don't even
need your dark square bishop which is
crazy but true
yeah that's why at first i was like oh
i'll move my white square bishop back
but no i can and we're showing we can
just take and push pawns forward and win
the game so janupomshi the fact that he
builds up a big lead on the clock is
huge for him
but here comes h6 played knight takes f7
maybe you don't have to take on f7 but
that's
where my eyes are glued
well the other move is the immediate uh
e4 e5 counter attacking the knight which
leads to
complete and utter guess the black queen
could get trapped in that line by the
way
hgef looks totally innocuous knight
takes f6 what's the big deal the big
deal is that the queen is trapped on b8
in this line and if you play bishop
takes f6 well that's a much inferior
version there's knight d6 there's all
sorts of shenanigans here that white has
yeah no it's uh
just a position that's starting to look
very difficult for black but what i
don't like for demetri and draken is
that he's down to three minutes jan has
time to work through the complications
dimitri he's gonna have to trust his
intuition a little bit more but he's not
doing that right he's he's deliberating
which is great as a chess commentator as
a coach we say
right clap clap our hands you know you
should be calculating but now you have
two minutes and 45 seconds
yeah and navigating the byzantine
complexities of that position is going
to be an incredibly tall order even with
six minutes and there it is the sack on
f7 you called it straight away did you
see jan i don't think he fully expected
this
he has the not impressed face on he just
took a sip of his tea i don't think he's
too unhappy to see this he knows this is
going to give him winning chances
he knows that if this backfires this
will probably lose and he knows that
dima is in time pressure so
if bishop h7 here donya i would just
like
quit and he didn't do it that would be
nuts
the most inhuman move ever bishop does
black take the opportunity then to
escape to g8 no jan simply takes on
before as if nothing is the matter as if
f5 is not coming on this on the next
move that's why he should shoot a vibe
check bishops oh
oh no
i think that's the crusher yeah it is
and yan finds it pretty much immediately
uh dimitri completely forgot about that
he can't move his king because the other
bishop
kills the king there with knight f4
check
oh and then this is just over them
if your best move is bishop d4 knight c3
now take advantage of a pin piece oh
f takes c6 you just drop the king back
to g8 that was my plan
and you say my king is as safe as it
gets what about yours
whoa but yani rushed it
wait what is actually what did he just
do here
and when everything is said and done
robert when you take
three times on d4 white plays rook f2
and guess what the threat of bishop h7
check is going to get right right back
into the game
and you asked about the yawn of old this
is one of those examples he has so much
time remaining
take a minute because if you find one
move the game is over on drake and
resigns you win the rcc basically yes
and now all of a sudden black could be
lost in just a few moves right we see
the eval bar saying it's not much of
anything but for e takes d7 here
young has a lot to figure out
unbelievable and
jan i apologize for the for the
ambulance that's coming after jan's
queen
bishop h7 or the rook wait so you have
to give up the king h8 what
what do you do
oh you have knights c3 here
and that if we pull up an analysis board
leads to i believe a bailout dc
rook c8 bishop h7 check is actually less
complicated than it appears king takes
h7
and black should not lose this right
yeah even if black lost both those
queenside pawns i'm still not sure black
loses this so yeah this is uh
a hold
and what a save this is gonna be behind
drake and it seemed like the game was
over after bishop c5 check
and it perhaps should have been
unreal will yan find
knight c3 it seems to be the only move
you know you know when annotations are
made there's exclamation point question
mark that's how this game went to meet
you with an exclamation point of knight
g5 takes f7 and then a big question mark
of f4 to f5 so
it's like uh
some brilliance some shaky moves but
right now yawn he's spending time but he
probably wishes he spent this time
several moves back
well queen takes e5 you get the
temptation of that move it has a certain
it has a certain aura to it it looks
like it's the winning move but he just
didn't calculate it he took five seconds
in that position
a
very uncharacteristic and
i mean to use that specific word a very
uncharacteristic mental lapse
for the new yon
and
i get why he made this play he just took
a piece on d4 with check and he's up a
minor piece you think oh i calculated
here but then you see rook f2 my rook on
c8 under attack my queen is about to be
lost so young uh he's not going to be
happy with this one but the good news
for him is he did just play knight c3 i
don't think he's losing this position
and if that's the case he gets game two
with the white pieces yeah he he
should and i'm sure will focus on the
positives yes this was the topsy turvy
game
but he also could have lost it he can
console himself by saying that if
dimitri had found the right move after
king takes f7 black's king
is caught in the crossfire there so
when all is told a successful result for
young assuming this game
will indeed fizzle out
and i'm trying to see if there's any way
dimitri can like queen e6 oh he played
as soon as i was
or am i crazy oh the rook is pinned oh
my god
if rook is pinned otherwise there'd be
mate yeah you would take twice on c8 and
then you'll go
incredible and then those darn chess.com
bugs not letting you play rook favorites
full of glitches
so what does dimitri do here is there
queen g6
bishop e4 oh boy then i probably just
get myself a losing position don't i
wait what is the it's zeros according to
the bar
it's zeros according to the bar
but
i think you need something cold blooded
like queen f5
and then if
you took your first oh because now you
can't play you can't play bishop before
because right but you play knight e4 oh
my goodness
yeah knight e4 and then
try that out for size with a minute on
the clock
but i think that's the solution here the
knight after queen f5 knight e4 cuts off
circulation the battery between the
bishop and the queen and it puts
pressure on the pinned rook and if you
take the 94 you lose your rook on d1
with check
right
and then after 94 white should probably
just calmly play a takes before and
sign the piece of chords after the match
trade on f2 what a ridiculously calm
move to play a takes b4 here right just
nothing's the matter we're fine
everything's defended
let's just take some pawns
and it just makes perfect sense bishop
takes e4 is clearly not good after queen
takes d1 check so 18 no other moves
i mean whether you like it or not
process of elimination did you see
dimitri there he's like i cannot believe
that all this just happened and that
we're here and we're just going to be an
ego
yeah he's running through the very
familiar gamut of emotions
and he's being been doing a lot of head
shaking listen we've all been there
having beaten hikaru and wesley
same tournament and now
saving a game against young we all know
what that's like
and dimitri has made it to the finals of
the world cup and for those of you who
follow chess you know that that is a
ridiculously impressive accomplishment
because you have to win matches against
grand master after grand master after
super grand master so it just you know
he he has experience in match format uh
but yeah right now you can tell that
he's been through a lot in these last
few games
jan spending his remaining time trying
to find ways to spice this position up
but he's
run out of fuel like he just doesn't
have enough pieces to cause actual
problems to black's king to white's king
knight takes f2 gets checkmated on h7
that's actually critical
and uh
we're on a cincinnati rookie eight
actually jan is still trying
all right but these end games like let's
say you move your bishop to
c2 and we trade everything on f2 only
white can be better there
yeah i don't know why yon
is pressing his luck like this
queen f7
okay just putting immediate pressure on
this rook i mean dimitri is just trying
to force yon to play queen takes up two
he's like enough of this nonsense just
take my rook already
but i actually mean it that white is
better in the ensuing end game
no we we saw on draken do this to fedo
sayo no 100
and the problem is black has
a king that's not particularly safe
exactly because the bishop controls the
luft square and in a time scramble yawn
now down to a minute on the clock we
know that anything can happen we know of
on draken's end game wizardry bishop b7
and c6 yan somehow keeps the tension
still
so bishop c2 is a move i really like
here
we can't take on e4 the rook on d1 is
loose but after bishop c2 i think at
long last the trait on f2 is mandatory
and when that happens rook d6 is a
threat
i really think that i'm drinking press
queen e3 could you still do that oh my
god
i think it very much consistent with
jan's style to play queen e3 and he's
thinking here which means that it's very
likely he makes it like queen e3 but the
longer he thinks the greater the
possibility that he just says hey i
don't want to lose this game either
but no after queen takes two it's like
the worst version of that endgame
because now the rook is heading to d6
right has gone dug himself into a hole
there's queen e3
what a move i have a queen f4 oh you can
take on that two with the knight
oh my god a knight h3 and the rook
blocks the check on d8 yeah that's
actually
10 seconds for dimitri you gotta go he
has four bars of connection so i'm
looking at that no same
five seconds what are you doing three
seconds dimitri
one second oh my gosh it was b5
so wait if you just trade everything on
f2 now and take b5 and there's rookie
two check at the end so i think black
could potentially go up upon here gosh
and jan will go up on but dimitri rook
d2 and he should be able to hold this
bishop g6 rook
i just get my work behind that pass pawn
and five seconds for the rest of the
game dimitri has his work cut out for
him bishop v8 great move by jan
this is dangerous territory for dimitri
on draken extremely rook d8 is gonna
come if you play king d2
so we have all ty gosh time to start
bringing that king in for black right
at some point you can't win the game
without it oh he pushes bishop f7 does
he want
oh there's rook
oh
he missed the tactic he's have it again
no because the bishop can't get to the
other diagonal
but if rook b1 is rook d8 takes
point nine seconds on that move
no no no
oh my gosh zero
if he saves this game jan is going to be
furious
but there's no way now the pawn is
landing on b3
just bringing his kingdom he's
completely winning
how did yon do that
dimitri got himself into too much time
trouble wait wait wait wait do bishop c
oh rook
okay rook f3
i feel like there's
the immediate major moves move demetri
one second
oh my gosh wait can jan play bishop yeah
g3 bishop f5 making
move he's gonna flag he flagged no he
didn't
he had zeroes for like five minutes
his position was completely lost so
normally i would feel bad when somebody
uh loses on time like that but now okay
this was just to show this was the
moment on move 42 what a yon could have
gone rook d8
and then rook takes d3
bishop g6 that would have ended the game
faster
what an unbelievable effort by jan to
produce those winning chances was that
incredible or what it was an absurd game
because at first
we thought that dimitri would have the
attack but then he aired with his f4 f5
it was completely winning for yon
somewhere uh in there it was complicated
but tactically speaking he had the upper
hand and then he rushed his decision so
yonda pomshi i think maybe in part
because he knows he can lose the first
match and still get a second match he's
like a little too calm as he pours his
tee off to the off screen here uh but
yeah that was a topsy-turvy game and now
a must-win game for dimitri on draken
with the black pieces against john's
catalan which has been not only
unbreakable but jan has just been
playing it for a win
how is dimitri going to handle this task
i'm silent because i just don't know how
you beat you i don't know either
you don't
you play something very sharp maybe
maybe early d take c4
and like knight c6 there's a lot of
lines that black can play in the catalan
to give yourself chances but i think
dimitri is going kind of for the long
game here he just wants to position with
a lot of pieces on the board and look at
yon he's saying no d takes c4 stuff for
you
i'm just going to play a very
nice safe game because you need to beat
me
where i know the ideas which is maybe
the worst thing i mean jan knows all of
these
where to put the knight on d2 when to
put it on c3
and if a person knows an opening that
well you're not beating them most of the
time yeah we might get like one of these
knight e5 knight fd7 type of positions
so look at dimitri he's pressing forward
on the queen side he knows he needs to
do something out of the ordinary now e4
is the stock move in such positions
and ion plays it and dimitri needs to do
something random yeah knight a6 sure
yeah he's unbalancing the position which
is what you have to do
and john says okay your knight wanted to
go to b4 no not for you today
no knight before for you but jan he
needs to be a bit careful here because
black is getting ready to play c5
and especially with the queen on c2 and
a rook coming to c8
that could be a bit of a nuisance
right with a big space advantage like
that and a big chunk of the center comes
great responsibility
so you absolutely have to tread
carefully if you're yawn but i like the
move b3 this completes the development
or prepares to complete the development
with bishop b2
that's right and it's just so solid how
is he going to lose this
wait c5 i think has a
oh it doesn't it takes a
yeah that's what i was looking for and i
think that white
should be absolutely no worse there that
might lead to total liquidation too
which is even worse
so he takes on e4 but this is clearly
better for white oh this is bad for
black knight
maybe not 95 just yet maybe like a
bishop move
issue f4 bishop f4 yeah
good night in a6 right they're not
phenomenal it's actually
semi-threatening to go to c5 which is
kind of funny
but no dimitri i mean he's he's trying
to unbalance the game but as a
consequence he's just much worse and
that's that but sometimes you have to do
that right like we saw
abby previous fabi against alexis
serrano just playing kind of random
stuff just for the long game and
jan correctly puts bishop on that f4 so
what can black's plan b you want to play
c5 but now after knight e5 you just can
never make that move
yeah knight e5 just sitting on black
completely you can also play
no this is i was thinking of playing
like rook a e10 but that drops the a3
pawn you don't want to do that
yeah 95 is definitely the move here
goes for it and this is just
kind of miserable for black i'm
yeah i'm struggling to come up with an
idea i mean yon just might win this
outright it's plus two
it looks like a plus two position yeah
oh
like white can play h4 rook e1 rogue d1
all these sort of things but as you you
made mentioned earlier don't drop a3
that would be like one of these blunders
that you can make right that would be
tragic
knight g4 by yan i was indicating that
but i actually didn't notice the black
has bishop g5
that
somewhat changes my mind on the move but
you know you could also take and just go
back to e5 i mean again
how
is black going to win this position just
don't blunder f5 right like some kind of
f5
right you just don't want to
run into that it doesn't work
in the current position but
that's the only way i could see black
somehow
just doing anything i love that jan is
taking his time
but i think dimitri also loves that
young's taking this time that's true
yeah he's just yeah he's deciding what
to do here like think about how dimitri
lost that last game it was even but
dimitri started getting in time trouble
and he started he gave away his b pawn
and here if yon guess in time travel
which never happens
then dimitri could probably
find some tactical sequence that
confuses them
yeah jan is not a huge yada is not a fan
of time scrambles at all he tries to
avoid them at all costs
so dimitri's got to keep all the pieces
on the board go rook fd8
just
hang around hang around and
you know keep your fingers crossed
you'll get an opportunity but the way
jan is playing i i'm really pessimistic
right white can just like rook e1 but
don't drop your a3 pawn i actually think
that it's not out of the realm of
possibility that white just blunders
that pawn because i would blunder that
pawn
yeah
it's not a common
source of contact queen on e7 pressuring
the pawn on a3
i'm not even sure if it's bad to blunder
that pawn like because it distracts the
black queen g5 or something yeah yeah
but no
you definitely should not be giving away
that pawn rook f1 is the move
h5 okay dimitri play h6 i would guess
now i think john will go rookie one nope
95.
so is it c5 time yet
i think it might as well
yeah i think it is c5 time and i think
jan is inviting it
and he's going to try to trade all the
pieces but
with the open center like that it's it's
a game you know
it's a game
it's one of these situations down here
where it's like practical versus
objective
yes the eval has sort of equalized the
engine says that
white lost most of his advantage but if
he can just trade queens and make sure
he can never possibly lose then it was a
good choice but i actually
yeah i'm starting to feel this a little
more for dimitri even though
it's far from a position where he can
play for
a win it just seems like he has more
chances
well if the d file opens and jan is the
one who controls it completely then i
just don't see black getting any chances
so let's see what dimitri came up with
here he trades
yeah b4 and uh i don't see this
happening he wants some kind of 94
knight g5 please let me checkmate you in
the light squares but
that's not happening and there's this
very typical idea of driving the pawn up
to b5 and establishing an outpost for
the knight on c6 they make matters even
worse for black
now this is this is pretty miserable
and
i mean dimitri has had a fabulous day
but
game one of this match danya just giving
away that position by giving first
losing the pawn getting in time trouble
uh that just did him in
yeah but earlier on in that game we'll
revisit it but not playing bishop h7
check going up in exchange
you know going to that very tense
position
and giving yan a chance to
squeeze the life out of that position
an unfortunate ending but
doesn't take away from
as you said out of
a historic day honestly for different
dimitri
beating wesley and hikara back to back
in matches that is
something very few people have done if
anyone has really done that but uh right
now let's see is there any chance for
dimitri i just with rook d1 making such
a logical move right now
and a queen d7 to follow just
how in the world do you win this no you
don't knight g5 doesn't even threaten
anything because the knight on e5 is
covering the f3 square yeah queen d7 i
think we need seven ends it
and a draw for might be forthcoming
after queen d7
and here we go
queen eight queen e7 knight h3 track
might be the idea yeah the king h2 and i
know you're gonna win the f2 pawn but my
rook's landing on d7 i'm gonna win your
b6 pawn your f7 pawn
although you can't take on f7 at the end
of that line because of knight g4 check
but oh that's actually we should show
that i'm i mean i'm getting letters to
show that
93 can't go king f1 so
yeah we're seeing we're going to see
exactly this kind of line
because black is zero other choice
in the matter
yeah but there's also this big issue for
dimitri he can never play f6 and not
just because benfical told him he
couldn't but because the knight will
just sink in on g6 will have a
nice first class seat to the action and
there's nothing that black can do
and even in an end game there there's
all these mating nets with there's so
many games that have been lost because
of those mechanisms
with knight g6 and rook d8
look at dimitri he's like not even
looking at the screen he understands
that this is getting out of hand
but he has to move quickly i think
that's the only way he has
even a remote shot at getting this game
but the thing is he cannot avoid a queen
queen does he play queen eight i guess
that is the only way to avoid the queen
trade no then f4
oh that just ends it doesn't it knight
h3 king h2 yeah yeah yeah
so then he has to play knight h3 i don't
think there's much to think about here
no it's the only opportunity for him
maybe he's just kind of letting it all
sink in that yeah he's not gonna get
this match but
this is definitely not the way to
make the attempt right now
no 100
but you lose with the white pieces to in
in a match like this you usually don't
have
that great of a chance anyway
it's similar in the world cup
which is the other big
two game
uh match tournament where if a player
loses with white in the first game there
have been pretty famous
cases of of players winning on demand of
the black piece is always
so impressive
but
it's
very few and far between
right so still
thinking is dimitrion draken
and now his clock is down a 537 the same
as yon's clock
he doesn't even have that anymore
and then
i'm just getting curious as to what's
going on in his mind but it's probably
just uh
letting his his feelings finally you
know after
three straight tough matches you know
it's hard to be disappointed in theory
when you beat wesley sonakara nakamura
but now that he's in the final i'm
guessing he's like i wish i could have
given this a better fight
well i think he's thinking yeah if i had
drawn the first game and
you know
this game would have been up for grabs
it's uh he regrets i mean it's ten
thousand bucks it's a lot of money
that's on the line and you know how
chess players work we're all
unbelievably tough on ourselves
and he's not sitting there saying i'm
going to give myself a pat on the back i
beat a car in wesley he's
going after himself for losing that
first game that's that's why we watch
it's true and that's how these players
get as good as they are is that right
yeah they can win
eight games out of nine in the nine-run
tournament like yeah but that game i
lost you know i really just didn't play
my best and it's like we you just beat
all these people
hashtag
beating everybody at the olympia but the
one game he lost against abusataro
that's the one that ends up sticking out
the most so
knight h3 check played after three and a
half minutes
obviously that was a move he could have
played in okay so i can fight we have
waited so patiently where i can show
you seven knight g4 checked really
quickly yeah that but this position
no come on
i think jan specifically chose this
because it's so drawn rookie savannah
takes c6 yeah it's just
well rookies
yeah i guess you could protect
everything
you could also play with d7 yeah and
rook f4 might just like even be better
for white yeah it is it is but rookie 7
is
clinical if you're making a draw if you
want to make a draw exactly
that's the luxury of winning the first
game
and
wow
funny mindset to have right it's like oh
i know i'm better with rook f4 but let
me play rookie he offered a draw
actually and i think dimitri
declines it oh wow let's go dimitri i
like that spirit right no
nothing to lose you might as well make a
couple more moves i always have felt
that way if you're in a two-game match
a draw and you lose the first game a
draw is the same as a loss so why not
just lose the game fight it's literally
the same as a loss right yeah who i
don't think dimitri on dragon cares
about his online rapid rating right now
no
what do you mean i i heard him
getting nervous about it the other day
he was
okay it's plus four
okay i think i i can understand why
young offered the draw
that isn't like an obnoxious move or
anything because he's completely winning
knight g6 i think is good enough
mm-hmm i have yeah yeah oh knight d7 is
coming
oh gosh knight c6 if that weren't good
enough 97
yep yeah and i think dimitri might
reciprocate the draw for right about now
and then you're gonna see jan decline it
right just out of principle there was a
famous incident in the world cup
where ivan chuck was playing geary
and i think vaseline won the first game
the second game you know vaseline plays
a nice game he outplays anisha and she
offers him a draw
now
in that situation a draw is almost
tantamount to a win but vastly declines
it
and he ends up making the draw anyway he
gets upset i mean he he advances against
anishi but he's upset he didn't win that
second game he doesn't care about the
result of the match
that's really funny i mean fabiano the
last round of the candidates when he
beat gorsuch all he did was a draw and
he said ah my position is pretty good at
this point let's play on but right now
john's position is amazing oh he did
that fabby declined a draw i don't know
i think a draw was offered at some point
wow
yeah he uh just played on one but
there's difference there right like the
uh feed a rating is very important to
those players
um right now i think that dimitri is
more focused on the result than ig six
mate oh gosh can you play rookie
no hesitation yep that fork ends the
game
we have the winner of our inaugural rcc
season
unbelievable and i think that was some
applause there for
dima yeah i mean i've seen ghosts no but
if we're being honest right coming into
this match just making it through the
losers bracket was an accomplishment
enough but no matter who made it through
yon is the heavy favorite because he can
afford to lose one match and then get an
immediate second one and so for dimitri
he knew that he was the underdog even if
they were playing just two games but the
fact that he would have to win two
matches around congratulations are in
order to jan napomneshi the winner of
the candidates tournament twice in a row
now the winner here at the rapid chess
championship you can see on the screen
the loser takes home second place and
twenty thousand dollars that's for
dimitri and draken thirty thousand
dollars
ready to go to yonder palm street bank
account
we could not have asked for a better
finale that first game was exhilarating
jan and dimitri are both just
monsters they're in incredible form
but right now yan is just
i mean
i have no words for him he is a force to
be reckoned with he's winning every
tournament that he's playing in
and
like we were discussing you can just
sense the confidence and the precision
emanating from his fingertips we saw
that again today
i mean just
a great display throughout this entire
event by jan napom shin uh you know to
get invited here to then win the matches
he had to including against hikaru
nakamura and then against dimitri on
draken but i think
in some ways the star of the show just
because it was less expected has been
demetrion draken so even though he
finishes in second place he deserves a
world of credit for his performance
he absolutely does to go through the
losers bracket like he did that game
against ikaro nakamura will remain in my
opinion as one of the the best
positional efforts in rapid i mean even
by the standards of a classical game
that was an absolute masterpiece so
demetrian draken he will hold his head
up high he can hang his hat on those 20
000 dollars that he has received as his
prize and obviously his regular season
as well with that second place finish
behind hikar nakamura was nothing short
of amazing as well
for sure and the games may have
concluded but the action has not because
we are going to bring in uh the players
for an interview so stay tuned everybody
we'll be back here with the interview
with yonda pomshi the winner of the
rapid chess championship finals
presented by coinbase
[Music]
so
the rapid chess championship is brought
to you by coinbase whether you're
looking to make your first crypto
purchase or you're an experienced trader
coinbase has you covered you can earn
crypto by learning about crypto at
coinbase.com explore d5 and web3 with
your coinbase wallet get exclusive
rewards when you spend with your
coinbase card and much much more learn
more at
coinbase.com and get 10 in bitcoin when
you sign up and verify your account
check them out use the command sponsor
or command coinbase today and go to
coinbase.com to get that bitcoin baby
it is our pleasure to be joined by the
rapid chess champion yonda palmashi jan
it seems like you like being interviewed
by me and dania because you keep winning
events
then you know that was my goal to speak
to you two guys yeah
missed you a lot
it's been a while
it's been a while since the candidates
yeah time flies
um jan uh i wanna rewind start by
rewinding a little bit to your win
against ikaro nakamura yesterday
uh we were talking uh a couple of times
about the hikaru effect the
psychological pressure that hikaru puts
on players particularly in online games
did you feel that at all and if so uh
how did you surmount that and what are
your thoughts about do you think that
win was your most important win of the
rcc finals
it's hard to say probably i'm was more
affected by i don't know effect
uh which affected me in the first game
so which i mean okay by no means i
had no you know no right to do this game
yeah just having slightly better with
zero risk and then okay going to 19
gaming yeah once it got tricky he played
just brilliantly
i guess he used most of his chances but
uh
yeah so
it was more or less some moronic effect
which was like uh
castleton myself
uh and
yeah second game was quite unfortunate
because
i think uh it's
you know i guess lately hikaru prefers
to play some soviet positions and
overall i would say this not quite his
cup of tea especially when he ran out of
his prep it's it's too chaotic
and the armageddon game i think it was
typical armageddon game so black let's
say achieved everything he could dream
about and then uh you know when you have
everything you don't know what to do and
uh
uh that's somehow which
something
you know what happened to me for many
times and i'm get only both colors so
when it's you know too close to
to the goal you start like doing some
nonsense and
yeah if the opponent managed to keep the
game going it's already
it's uh you know already difficult to
keep your head cool
i mean john you mentioned that second
game and how he ran out of his
preparation how do you as a top level
chess player decide when to use some
kind of deep preparation maybe a novelty
so how did you you know choose those
moments
well
frankly speaking i think in jerusalem we
used this uh
bishop 65 idea
uh which is quite smart but uh
i think yeah it requires
quite a bit of knowledge
so yeah i'm just yeah training uh
i mean
in some way i was happy to have some
extra magnum games to play them with
white to train some catalan so
because i think last time i played
catalan uh
less
more or less you know frequent opening
was when i was 10.
and lately it was only like time to time
but
yeah for now it's
some new experience and uh
every extra white game is
a big relief
jan were you watching uh the
undrained matches before your match and
if so
uh who were you was there somebody you
were hoping to face or
is there no difference to you you're
focusing instead on your own on your own
game well
first of all kudos to dmitry because she
just yeah i think he did just great she
i think swindled wrestling in quite a
suspicious position in
uh in the first uh
in the first match and then uh
yeah it was never easy but he
he managed to hold it in the game one
and then game two i think he just
uh outplayed and
just yeah was
just i think just a big positional
achievement
and yeah it's quite sad that probably
after playing you know after having such
a tough schedule he he wasn't you know
as fresh
against me and obviously yeah he
yeah he gambled too little he i think he
keeps under a lot of things
i mean we
we discussed uh you know games just
just a little bit after
after the management yeah just
completely outstanding and once again
i mean i'm i'm i'm really sorry he
couldn't make it best in our match
well yeah one of the big
story lines of this event is the
armageddon bidding format so against
hikaru you bid the full 10 minutes to
get the white pieces how do you choose
how much time you're going to bid does
it depend on the opponent does it depend
on how the match has gone what goes
through your head
as i said before i was just willing to
train uh catalan for ways
no no jokes no jokes i mean i swear
okay it would be like quite uh
quite tricky if someone would uh you
know outclass me and pick 9.59
so
i think even then you know the
educational educational part would be
really priceless for me
john final question for me
could you rate your overall rcc
experience regular season and finals on
a scale of one to ten and can we expect
you
uh to play consistently in the weekend
rcc's next season
well uh somehow i think i was
i was trying to
to play more or less often when it was
like the first half until uh
okay until
the candidates camp uh and then booker
restaurant started and then a little bit
gave up on it
and then i was like i think i was
puzzled with the scoreboard they
probably anyway i don't qualify i can
i can't even skip last two
last two tournaments and then uh
suddenly i understood
so yeah last two last two legs were a
little bit
yeah tricky
uh but uh yeah once again thanks for
giving me the wild card to the finals
it's uh yeah it's an honor and yeah it
worked out perfectly
uh yeah obviously i like uh i like this
ten plus two format
and
at the same time i don't quite like this
ten plus or ten plus o
uh in the in the swiss part but
yeah and also and also perhaps i would
also uh say that probably it would be
you know uh
more uh more wise to grant
let's say in the key of ours yeah uh you
should
[Music]
choose uh
you know you should give the right to
choose to the you know to the higher
seed
which color does he play the first game
with
uh because in my opinion uh
like uh i mean okay
of course it's matter of taste but i
mean somehow again some opponents you
want to start with black and against
someone you want to start your white
i mean yeah it's
it's uh always you know it's it's always
tricky but yeah somehow
it shouldn't be like this but yeah
otherwise yeah
i'm always going to run and yeah hope to
return
well speaking of formats yan you are not
just uh super grandmaster and chess you
like other games like dota and
hearthstone uh so what do you think
about the double elimination format it's
not used much in chess and you didn't
really have to use it yourself because
you didn't lose a match but what do you
think of the double animation format
uh well it
i mean it was cool because it it
reminded me of a good old delta types
here
because in don't uh you must play double
elimination
but as for me i think i
was saying to fiji for many times that
for for example for the world cup it
would be very fair if we can
you know find a solution
like which which benefit which benefit
do we grant to the you know the winner
of the upper bracket uh let's say in the
super final uh in the grand final if we
find like a decent uh decent bonus for
uh
coming to the great finance without a
loss
then it would be like an an awesome
addition to the world cup because uh
guys some somehow like this you know
these kios system tournaments are too
rough
so yeah it was some you know nostalgie
for me to play at least and yeah but
of course no one wants to go to the
lower bracket here
well you certainly did not find yourself
there so once again massive
congratulations to you yan napoche we're
getting very accustomed to saying that
so a job well done and we look to seeing
more excellent chess from you
thank you thank you very much
and there you have it your rapid chess
champion
jan napomischi he takes down compatriot
and friend dmitry andreikin in the grand
finals uh the 2-0 score that doesn't
necessarily tell the whole story there
because game one was fascinating but we
have more exciting events just because
the rapid chess championship is over
with does not mean we don't have more in
store for you but good luck prepping for
this tournament because you will not be
able to chess.com is hosting
two to 2022 official random world
champion qualifiers on august 22nd and
august 29th who win a spot in these
qualifiers to face reigning fisher
random world champion wesley soh and
world chess championship magnus carlson
i don't know but don't miss out on this
exciting format right here on
chess.com and no surprises here
as we get to that part of the day it is
your coinbase rapid recap and dania we
had no choice we have to pick a game
from the winner janna pomache
we do indeed and the game that we picked
is his first game in the finals the
grand finals against
dmitry and drake and jan has the black
pieces
in this game and dimitri and jacob had
just
finished defeating hikaru nakamura
um and wesley so and here he is facing
yan with white the opening robert pretty
tame uh dimitri repeats the opening that
brought him success against ikaro
nakamura but very quickly jan displays
astute opening preparation and gets the
game right away into a complicated
middle game that's right because this
looks just like simple development but
after black castle and strikes with c5
he's taking advantage of the fact that
white's king is in the center and
white's made a bunch of pawn moves so
after the capture on c5 and the queen
comes to c2 here
dmitry says i'm okay with the fight i'm
not just going to trade queens to try to
make a draw and it did become a fight
and it became a fight very quickly jan
develops his knight to d7 in order to
not obstruct the long diagonal once he
develops his bishop and a very big move
by dimitri e4 super committal there are
clear drawbacks he weakens the dark
squares he opens the diagonal for a
black's bishop but it's quite clear that
he is setting uh the preconditions for a
potential e5 pawn push jan stops him in
his tracks with queen c7 and after
knight b8 and b4 we felt that dimitri
kind of started taking over the
initiative and the next critical moment
occurred a couple of moves later both
sides developing their remaining pieces
dimitri forced to drop his bishop back
to defend that e4 pawn and robert here
we suddenly felt that jan started losing
control of the game he played this very
impulsive move knight h5
usually being influenced by wesley so is
a good thing but just like wesley
against andreikin two matches prior this
knight maneuvering did not help because
it does threaten knight f4 g3 stops that
and because the knight is in danger of
being stuck on the side of the board
with e5 and as you're pointing out the
queen is looking at that diagonal he
goes knight back to f6 but this gives
white the time to launch an attack first
with the rook coming to d1 another pawn
to a5
in comes the knight to g5 and all of a
sudden there are tactics galore
tactics galore indeed and demetrian
draken does not hesitate he sacks on f7
opening up black's king an idea that you
called reminiscent of certain lines
within the meron sloth he follows up
with the move e5 and the critical moment
of the game occurs after knight d5
black's king seeks to mount its escape
to g8 and apparently this is an
incredibly difficult move to find bishop
h7 would have stopped the king from
escaping and given white long lasting
attacking chances the position here is
tremendously unclear but instead dimitri
he went for a plan that is a too slow
and b to weakening he shoves the f-pawn
up the board but robert after f5 jan
beautifully revealed the flaw in
dimitri's ointment here yeah it would
seem like it's black's king it's in
grave danger but look at white's king
bishop c5 check that's a check in the
dark squares and then look at the light
squares the bishop on b7 acting like a
sniper so dimitri was forced to trade
off attacking pieces and here the move
knight c3 was a brilliant shot it was
just trying to distract white's pieces
away and the knight needs to stay put
defending the bishop unfortunately too
many of white's pieces are under attack
but instead young rushed a little bit
with queen 65 and dania this gave on
draken a chance
and this led to a forced line after f
takes c6 king g8 yan calculated all the
way up to this moment what he didn't
realize is that after rook f2 not only
is the black rook hanging but there is
also the devastating threat of bishop h7
check this forced dion to think on his
feet he found the only move not to lose
that's knight c3 and here dimitri had a
chance to essentially bail out into a
risk-free end game by taking the queen
and playing bishop h7 check the game
would have ended in a draw should he
have chosen this continuation but
instead dimitri keeps the tension he
gives a check on e6 he takes on c8 and
he goes for a position that sure looks
incredibly promising for white but
robert uh that happened to be an
illusion and it's actually white who
happens to be on the defensive here
that's right because for the time being
knight e4 cuts off the battery between
bishop and queen which is threatening
queen h7 checkmate now the rook and f2
remains pinned by the queen the bishop
on d3 is pinned because the rook on d1
is lewis and that forced
drake to play the very calm of eight
takes before which is a good move
restoring pawn equality although now
it's an extra exchange for white after
the next couple was rookie eight queen
from bishop c6 at this point after
bishop c2 this is a great decision with
only a min uns clock because queen takes
f2 if you just force the pieces off the
board then white actually has the upper
hand because look at the piece activity
the bishop cuts off the king's escape
square the rook coming to d6 which
attacks that b6 bond so white is first
to the activity here and then black
would be having a tough task to defend
so instead of this queen e3 and the
point is that i mean dimitri went wrong
here with b5 but if queen went back to
f4 then there's this move knight takes
f2 because queen takes e3 it looks like
the rook has to take in their back rank
problems but first knight h3 check then
you take on e3 and there is no
background checkmate because the bishop
and rook team up to defend the e8 square
well explained and it turns out that
queen takes f2 was indeed one of the
ways to force a drawn game but instead
dimitri with only seconds left on his
clock he panics and plays b5 this allows
yon to finally take that rook but at the
end jan picks up the extra pawn on b5
simultaneously threatening rookie 2. no
question that this is objectively a draw
but with only seconds left on the clock
and some lag issues on top of that and
jan's incredible conversion technique
dimitri was unable to hold this end game
first john put the rook behind the pawn
he brought the bishop back now a little
bit later as dimitri's position keeps
getting worse and jan keeps pushing his
pawn here jan had a chance to win the
game immediately with a check followed
by rook takes d3 he missed that but
robert the result of the game at this
point was already not in question
no it was not because of the excellent
technique from jan nepal he puts his
bishop on f7 then he's able to push his
pawn and a couple moves to b3 where it's
defended and the reason why this is such
an easy win is because you may think
that pawn on b3 can be attacked by
white's bishop as well but the only way
to get that pawn is use your bishop rook
and king at the same time but then that
pawn uses a decoy because the black king
will march in win the remaining white
pawns and there'll be a winning king and
pawn end game so there is no chance here
and jan he checks the king and it's not
like the white bishop was getting around
in time and dimitri had one last chance
i think instead of the move g4 right
there dania i believe rook f3 somehow
keeps chances alive but a very difficult
move to play without time on the clock
and even then he probably would have
lost and after bishop g6 the bishop
trade is inevitable the position is
completely lost here dimitri lost on
time giving on the critical win in their
first match game and jan easily held the
second game to win the rapid chess
championship that is your coinbase rapid
recap
yeah what a performance it was from yon
napomshi throughout the tournament you
know he went unblemished didn't lose a
single match and he won a couple in
armageddon he beat fedor sayyaf in that
third game he beat uh hikaru in a
wonderful third game with opposite
colored bishops where it looked like he
had no winning chances whatsoever so
yonder ponchi he makes it through he is
our rapid chess championship very
deserved performance from him
what a treat this has been to watch all
of these players
just at play in top form and taking this
tournament so seriously i think at the
end of the day what we saw in the
regular season what we saw in the
playoffs is that each and every one of
these players
be it the prizes be it just the pride of
calling yourself the rapid chess
championship champion over all of the
trials and tribulations of the regular
season these players took this as
seriously as the most serious classical
tournament and the results show the
quality of play was high it was
unbelievably entertaining and it was a
great honor and privilege to have
courtside seats to the action all four
of these days
yes it was a real spectacle and i'm glad
that i was able to have the call with
you and i thank all of our you know many
people in the audience who tune in each
and every day and i do want to give
another shout out to dimitri on draken
because you heard the champion janupomji
he was very
forthcoming with his praise of dimitri
he said he played two excellent matches
against wesley and akara and he felt
like he ran out of steam and you know
yan
being very humble almost apologized that
he felt like the final didn't have a
fully energized dimitri on draken but i
think that when all is said and done
dimitri would also agree that yon napalm
she's a deserving champion
he absolutely is he's been on such a
tear and this is just the continuation
of what has been
perhaps the most memorable year not even
perhaps definitely the most memorable
year most memorable few months of his
chess career and i just wanted to want
to say that
you know since uh this ends the first
inaugural season of the rapid chat
championship i've commentated so many of
these weekend rcc's a lot of them with
you robert it's been
it's been a great pleasure this has been
something i look forward to each and
every weekend
uh and you know i
just this is just such a great way to
enrich your weekend entertainment to see
these grand masters compete weekend in
and weekend out and to see it all
culminating in an amazing final i can't
think of anything better than that so
really really appreciate the opportunity
to have commentated as many rcc's as i
did and i'm looking forward to the
second season
well said partner that those words i
can't really follow up and i just want
to remind everybody of a few things that
the
history of chess a reflection of us that
video is released so please enjoy that i
want to remind everyone as well about
the women's speed chess championship
match tomorrow be between ho ifan and
valentina gunnino that's at 5 00 a.m
pacific time you will not want to miss
that the winner takes on caterina loch
no in the final and of course the fisher
random worlds championship which will
have a live final in reykjavik the
reigning champ is wesley so he took down
world chess champion magnus carlson a
few years back but qualifier one begins
tomorrow and it will be right here on
chess.com so on math of chess.com and
myself
down in eriditsky my co-commentator here
we want to thank coinbase for sponsoring
this event we want to thank our producer
matt for putting on great show after
great show and we want to thank all of
you and all the players for making this
the best possible event but we say
goodbye and see you soon because
tomorrow more action continues here on
chess.com
our final four players jan de palmici
has a leg up on the competition he can
lose two matches on route to a
championship here at the rapid chess
championship but three players wesley
soh dimitri andreikin hikaru nakamura
they're looking to unseat yon ponchi and
win the crown
this has been a stunning turnaround he
played three no no no no no not h5
knight h5
signed the score sheets
dmitry and draken
with the black pieces from a miserable
position somehow turns the tables in the
span of five moves okay dimitri gotta go
oh he's lagging and oh his clock is up
four seconds i'm afraid he's gonna lose
on time
no okay he got it he got it off it's
just so nerve-wracking this is over this
is a draw and ticaro offers one and so
does dimitri
whoo
what a slugfest he has prevented hikaru
from doing anything he's eating him
alive is he going to go he goes knight
takes four
good guy the guy is insane he just
doesn't give him even a single chance to
take a piece
is there a meeting there like if he just
plays b7 just play
oh my gosh he's just toying with him at
this point oh rook a7
that's it
dimitri on drake look at him and now his
reward is a showdown with yon de palmas
i think that dimitri has many new fans i
don't think after this we're gonna have
to say oh people overlook dimitri now
he's getting not anymore
jan simply takes on before as if nothing
is the matter as if f5 is not coming on
this on the next move that's why he
should vibe check bishops oh
oh no
i think that's the crusher yeah it is
and yan finds it knight c3 now take
advantage of a pin piece oh
f take c6 you just drop the king back to
g8 that was my plan
and you say my king is as safe as it
gets what about yours
whoa but yanni rushed it he has so much
time remaining five minutes take a
minute because if you find one move the
game is over on draken resigns you win
the rcc basically and five seconds for
the rest of the game dimitri has his
work cut out for him bishop he a great
move by jan this is dangerous territory
for dimitron draken bishop f7 does he
want
oh
he missed the tactic he's leave it again
no because the bishop can't get to the
other diagonal
but if rook b-1 is rook d-a takes b
0.9 seconds on that move
get a flag oh my gosh zero
major moves move demetrius one second
oh my gosh wait can john play bishop g
through bishop
[Music]
he flagged no he didn't
he had zeroes for like five minutes
knight g6 mate oh gosh he can't play
brook city
no hesitation yep that fork ends the
game for dimitri he knew that he was the
underdog even if they were playing just
two games but the fact that he would
have to win two matches around
congratulations are in order to jan
napomnishi
the winner of the candidates tournament
twice in a row now the winner here at
the rapid chess championship
[Music]
so
did
[Music]
you